if you're gonna be at the top you're
gonna piss some people off I chose
bodybuilding it didn't choose me but I'm
known for telling it like it is I don't
think anybody takes that away from me
people think I'm sour grapes that I
didn't bee Dorian
nobody be Dorian this same group of
judges likes chocolate this year they're
gonna like chocolate make sure you're
gonna like chocolate the next year so
now I'm a whiny [ __ ] did you and Chad
Nichols ever do anything together
absolutely not he's dr. Kevorkian to me
bro current era against your era they're
lucky that Dexter's not 10 years younger
top 5 greatest bodybuilders of all time
you're not gonna find me talking about
how to use anabolics with anybody you
ever gotten to fight with any of these
guys I pushed a lot of buttons trust me
whose fault is that dude I heard you say
something like what does the Olympia
doing for you athletes they don't owe us
anything it's just like boxing like
you're a boxer well this is what I make
this is not the NFL and it's not the NBA
you've got James flex Lewis coming back
hotty cheapens coming back does phillies
come back or not the Olympia does not
need to make the mister limp I'm not
saying that of course it doesn't
how can he sit at home and watch the
competition that made him who he is how
sensitive
you're sensitive in terms of what I
can't sit there and say oh you're upset
at me it's your fault are you kidding me
then Olympia was bigger and better than
it's ever been
even though Phil wasn't there on saying
it's bigger than any bodybuilder it's an
institution
[Music]
did you ever think you would make good I
feel like it takes sweet victory I know
this slice meant for me here yeah why
would you bet on Goliath oh we got
plenty now you came in given values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can't know value to haters honey run
homie look what I become I'm the one
[Music]
today we have another legendary
bodybuilder in value taemin studio this
is a man who may be considered one of
the most consistent dedicated mr.
Olympia competitors of all time he's
competed thirty times I believe
professionally only placed once outside
of the top five twelve years in a row
consecutively mr. Olympia was in top
five he's beaten pretty much everybody
he's ever faced off except I want to say
to people Yates and Haney I believe and
known as a business guy he's loved he's
hated he's got a lot of opinions he's
got a lot of things to say so we'd have
a good time today the one and only genre
Shaun thanks for coming out buddy it's
interesting because the love and the
hate that didn't come till I think I was
done bodybuilding I mean when you move
into the media side you have a lot of
people that have opinions I remember
Muhammad Ali had a love-hate
relationship with Howard Cosell and I
see what Stephen a Smith is doing now as
a talking head for all these other
sports and moving into the interview
side and the media side these guys that
you know I admired I'm now got a
critique and criticized and had some
threats from some bodybuilders because I
was too harsh with my criticism but I'm
known for telling it like it is and you
know I take the good with the bad so
loved and hated I take it what the heck
I mean if you're gonna be at the top and
you're gonna be competing for a while
and business you're gonna piss some
people off it doesn't matter who you are
yeah but for you your your slightly
different because you know from looking
at it from the outside to the
bodybuilding world okay you see guys who
you know they compete and they know how
to play the physique to have genetics
they have a nice physique but they don't
know how to play the politics game right
so they'll go compete but they'll never
voice off or sound off to get some kind
of change to take place nineteen ninety
five ninety five percent of them yeah
they're kind of quiet because they're
afraid what if the IFBB Oh what if mr.
Olympia brand does something wrong jaren
then you got the guys on the other side
there are good politics but they don't
have a physique right they understand a
political game but they don't have a
seat they're loud you have the physique
you have the gift you are an incredible
body build in your world even your
enemies when it comes up to talking
about genetics and you know how you came
in at 197 at first professionally at the
end I think
have you ever worse was like two 18 18
and you go through that but you also
understood the political game you saw
some of the stuff that was going on
behind closed doors and so today I kind
of you know on one end I want to kind of
get to know you to see what your stories
you know cuz I try to find a lot of
different stories about your past I know
your high school you know Pasadena guy
you got some interesting stories on what
you did but I want to go a little bit
more into this guy in high school Sean
Ray we're 14 years old I'm your
classmate this is pre you break into a
record 498 yard run that you went on and
it's in the book still today yeah yeah
you had the ability to go play college
maybe the next level you were 17 years
old debating to be a bodybuilder I'm
talking pre that 14 years old who's John
Wright I was a dreamer I wanted to play
professional football and you know had
already had experience with karate I
wrestled I started playing football at
the age of 8 I had come from a football
background all my brothers played
football so I knew that going to El
Dorado high school was my meal ticket
out I wanted to play in the NFL and I
could tell you the names of the players
their salaries the coaches on all the
NFL teams as a teenager so going into
high school my brother Chuck was one
year older than me he was a phenom and
as a freshman had all rushing records
but he was a fullback type runner I was
more of a Barry Sanders type runner so
he set the bar for me going into El
Dorado and he's kind of a bully a little
bit bigger version of me playing the
punk rock band he would defend his
friends in fights I was not a fighter
very spontaneous he would surf snow ski
and do all the things I wouldn't do when
I got to El Dorado I wanted to break his
record
but I also was aware of the senior and
the varsity records that were there so I
went in there with an agenda I wanted to
become a professional football player
and I did everything I could do my my
sophomore year they asked me to play
varsity and two games in I started and
from there I just you know continued on
I was a halfback I was a the punter I
was the kick returner the punt returner
the defensive halfback and the running
back so by the time I was a senior I was
pretty much I was helping the
quarterback call plays but at the same
time I was lifting weights to get bigger
faster and stronger which was very
effective before I left high school
I'd already won the Orange Coast
Championships and I won the teenaged
California my senior year and that's
when I knew I was gonna become a
bodybuilder you knew you were gonna be
about 1984 it was April I had gotten
injured my senior year stood on the
sidelines watched my varsity season
disappear and I had to make a decision
play in the all-star game in June or do
the teenage national championships in
June was 18 years old and I chose the
teenage national championships I went in
it got second place I lost that
competition to Franco santarilla as a
teenager but Franco had won at the year
before so he came back for a second
national title it was a little more he
was and then by the time I was 19 I went
back to the Nationals I won that
championship wound up in flex magazine
met to Joe Weider
and Ricky Wayne's son Kevin Wayne's a
photographer Rick Wayne saw a lot of
myself a lot of himself in me and I'm at
the Joe Weider studios at 19 years old
by 20 I was a junior world champion on
the cover of flex magazine in college
still no money but I was living the
dream I could drive to Woodland Hills
and walk in and see the pictures and see
see what the future potentially would
help holds for me and at 21 years old I
was a national champion three years out
of high school a professional and Joe
Weider signed my first $1,000 a month
contract $1,000 a month $700 apartment
$289 car payment I had to figure the
rest out it was sink or swim now let me
ask you back then it was more kind of
like look we don't have money to give
you but we'll put you on cover of
magazines but no I was I had nothing to
compare this with Joe Weider said they
had $1,000 a month and I thought that
that might as well have been a million
dollars a month for me I was in college
but he was calling my house I was
driving to his office we were having
these conversations they saw something
in me that I really still didn't get my
arms around at the time I won the Junior
World Championships in teenage America
they were saying that I was the next big
thing I hadn't bought into it yet mind
you I was coming up at the same time
Mike Tyson was and watching Mike fight
and listening to how he was being
indoctrinated into being the heavyweight
champion in the world by custom auto I
had my John Brown who found me as a
bodybuilder telling me the same thing
now I've got Rick Wayne
telling me the same thing what age did
John start telling you 17:17 s when I
joined a gym John won the mystery unit
using mr. universe two times and mr.
world three times when he saw me he
thought I was already training for
bodybuilding but I was training for
football six months later I was on stage
then I was his full-time training
partner for a year by the time I won the
teen national championships drama went
back to Europe I continued doing it my
way and I wound up becoming mr.
California first in 87 National Champion
in 1987 in November when I got my
contract though that validated the whole
thing because you got to remember I'm
coming from football yes in high school
I'm shaving my legs there's no hair I'm
just doing what I what it looks to be
normal I'm taking the bikini girls down
and putting all the muscle men up I'm
admiring and studying these books I mean
there's a lot of questions going around
about what am i doing walking away from
football but I knew that the way John
was telling me that I could kind of live
the life that he was living if I did the
things he did I believed it he was my
custom ATO and he did tell me that at
the time I could beat guys like rich
Gaspari and Lila Prada and the fact that
Samir Bannu was mr. Olympian 1983 Chris
Dickerson and 82 they were my size that
was the validation of why they were
telling you that's you can beat those
guys you're not gonna be that way and
then of course by time I was a senior in
84 Lee Haney won his first mr. Olympia
but it didn't deter me I mean Lee Haney
510 hmm 240 250 I still you know had Tom
Platts and Leela brought on these guys
that were on the shorter end during the
business if I just kept doing the things
I was doing I would be on my way when I
won the Nationals and got that contract
from Joe I was hooked and sunken-in let
me ask you say John Brown's not in your
ears are you still going to go to path
you you you ended up going or now um
probably not because without him telling
me when he first saw me I could beat
Doral Washington who was a mr. America a
teenager at the time and and I mind you
the other guy saw that was Victor
Richards which was on the other end of
the spectrum in terms of size I had the
right guys telling me the right things
at the right time and then when I looked
around I didn't see guys like Arnold and
guys like
Lee Haney I saw guys like LeBron in 1985
I saw Chris Dickerson at 42 years old
who I looked eyeball-to-eyeball with and
Samir Bannu and Tom Platts they were the
big names in bodybuilding and I fit
right into that height wise and weight
wise so proportionately I think I
started to believe John as an artist
that you know posing and presentation is
everything and you can beat some of
these guys on how you show your frizzy
you don't have to be as big and
understanding that as an artist coming
from John that indoctrination that I
could outperform them I could probably
beat them then I started getting best
poser award then I started winning the
overall Awards and I didn't need John at
that point by the time I was 21 years
old and won the Nationals I was on my
own it's it's so interesting when you're
saying like if a guy like that wasn't in
your ear you may have been doing
something else today well I probably
went back to football that was hurt the
power of somebody being in your ear to
say Shawn I believe one day you can
compete with these big guys and be able
to hang with any of these guys that are
up on this stage the power of that it's
so uh you when you look back and you
talk to a lot of guys and almost every
one of them that goes and competes at a
high level somebody in their life said I
believe you can be XYZ it's almost like
somebody painted a picture of a you
didn't believe you can be that person
but they painted it and you said you
know what I'm gonna go for this thing
over here that somebody else sees you
gotta remember the guy that's telling me
this he's got like two Mercedes
he's flying all around the world he's
speaking German he's making deals in
Paris he's a student of surgery Bray
he's friends with a lot of the people
that I see in the magazines we walk in
the world's gym and he's over there talk
in a borough Fox you know he's talking
with Tom Platts he's he's you know
rubbing elbows with Mike Christian these
are all the guys are in the magazines
that I want to be in one day I saw the
finish line so for me to see the finish
line as a teenager made me a little bit
more focused I didn't need to be at the
after parties after the football games I
didn't need to be running the streets I
need to be ready for that next workout
that John was preparing me for so so you
had an older brother did everybody know
it's kind of like when you went to high
school don't mess with Shawn because his
older brother is gonna whoop your tail
was it like that kind of a culture or
you know no it was it I'm in mind you
from a lily-white Orange County I mean
there was probably five black guys I was
the only one in my graduating class I
believe on the football team so we were
all athletes and nobody was picking on
me or my family for that matter you guys
had a reputation was like the Rain boys
or a family yeah an athletic reputation
my brother Reggie was a three-time
letterman in track and field basketball
and football
my brother Chuck was like the strongest
black kid period he was like in he had a
very short food fuse he was a fighter
got kicked off the football team yeah
you wouldn't take no crap from nobody
but where we came from there was no
really I didn't experience much racism
caught up and I think my sports
superseded all that I was good at
athletics I didn't have time to get in
trouble so they didn't treat me any
different and I didn't feel any
different but I was always the leader I
was the captain I was the MVP and I even
wants the brothers or no monk's brothers
the youngest of eight we had to mix a
blended Brady Bunch family my dad had
three kids when he met my mom my mom had
two kids when she met my dad then we had
one two and three in a row where are you
on that I'm the last so that my brothers
one year older my sister's two years
older last up to eight or last associate
or last thing they had all those
mistakes eat seven times I got this one
we're done now your parents personality
was how my mom the son of a janitor you
know and at the time when I was in
school grade school I think was more for
me out of an embarrassment my dad would
work those odd hours and when I get up
for school and go to the store with my
friends my dad would be in the parking
lot sleep at the wheel cuz coming back
from work and we're starting our day my
dad would he wore these overall painter
overalls when he did his janitorial
stuff and it was always be dirty and
just you always I always thought my dad
he's always dirty and I just kind of
thought man dad you're changing it
embarrass me go go get in the bed and
you know I would run for 150 yards 200
yards and come home and I'd be washing
windows the same night when I got it in
high school it was tough because my
friends would be going to the beach on
Saturday I'm going to wash windows clean
toilets and then it taught me something
that I got to be better than that I want
be better than my dad and naturally
through watching my dad struggle through
those years of I don't know I don't
think it was a struggle for him because
he worked till he died he died in 2010
for me I wanted something better and I
think my drive came from the fear of
cleaning toilets in washing windows
wasn't beneath me and the people that do
it I have a total affinity for I see
them all the time in the places that I
travel in going through the airports you
know I'm a sure I recognize those people
because that was my dad and now that my
dad's gone it's even more that I'm aware
of that we walk into a nice building
first thing my dad's looking at is the
floors and the windows and he's he's
pointing out all the stuff that people
just walk by and just gloss over but it
felt very redeeming for me to move out
of the house
to get my first car which was a Corvette
to be able to buy my dad lunches and
dinners and to be able to not have to
work for my dad and there did come a
time when we bumped heads and I was like
I'm not doing it no more I'm not I can't
I'm not I got to sleep I got a train and
when I was coming up in high school eat
sleeping and training he he looked at
that as a hobby by the time I started
getting paid for it I had to remind him
it was a career and we had some friction
were the age was that when you have
friction are there about 22 I just I
started feeling my manhood and I was on
the verge of buying a house and I had to
stand up as he let up you gotta find
some employees I'm not doing it but
everyone in my neighborhood worked for
my dad all the family work for my dad
now I'm at a point where I'm making my
own money I don't have to work for my
dad and I don't any my dad to tell me
what to do so I did go through this
phase like look man I'm self-made now
this is me this was not from you how
long did that last the friction probably
when I bought my house ultimately I
bought my house in 91 and my dad was
there from the beginning to the end to
help me through that process because
that's a major step I think I was 22 23
years old and it felt good to see my dad
pull up in the driveway you know and and
knock on the door and and see that this
sweat equity that I put in the gym this
did this you know and I never looked
down on my dad my dad did his janitorial
work until he died if anything I tried
to lift my dad up in a lot of ways
he wouldn't take any money for me so I
made sure you wouldn't take any money I
made sure he ate the nice steak houses I
made sure that so proud man very proud
because I would hear from other people I
saw your dad he was saying this I hear
about my life story from people that my
dad was talking to so it was for me
becoming a professional bodybuilder it
was something to make my dad proud but
it was also something that I was fearful
of becoming a janitor was he also was
y'all asking yeah he was also anybody
thought my dad was like a bodybuilder
but that's where you got to give credit
to genetics my mom just the opposite cpa
engineer we always said how did you dad
wind up having these kids you know it's
like he's totally the opposite but they
you know 18 years of marriage they got
divorced when I was 17 years old and I
was pretty much on my way as a
bodybuilder at the time and always when
after that after the divorce happened my
mom got remarried we were always a
family unit around the holidays so I
came from a very stable family with both
the work ethic of a blue-collar toilet
cleaner and the mind of an accountant
which was my mom and seep that's
powerful that's it that's a very good
combination right because you're getting
the hard work and you know likey you can
use the hard work to advance but also
you can use her brains put them together
you you know you are who you are
absolutely and by the way I was talking
to Ron from muscular development and we
were doing I was a guest on his podcast
yesterday and he says in my experience
there are two types of people that end
up doing well on bodybuilding one is the
kid that grew up and he was bullied and
this person has a point to prove so they
go into bodybuilding he says they don't
typically win but they do go into body
builder he said the other one is
somebody that was an athlete and they
were already an athlete they were
playing sports and then they went into
bodybuilding yes it's one of those
things when you find out what you want
to do at a younger age you typically can
get there faster Mike Tyson wanted to be
a heavyweight champion of the world at
15 16 years old he got there when he
stole your edge was finding out sooner
yeah I mean I I knew what I wanted soon
as I made up my mind at 17 that that's
what I wanted to do nothing came into my
life that was going to sway that in the
sixth immediate success I was having
like I had with football was validation
that I was on the right path and I mind
drama unicorn there's John Brown who
made his bones over in Europe and not a
lot of people knew who he was
and then there was me I didn't have
anybody to look to to compare notes with
I had to make the pilgrimage to gold
shim and read the magazines and be
pretty much self-taught John knew how to
train did I find you bother I walked
into his gym that he was training at and
he thought I was training for a show
nice you know I became his training
partner I should say punching bag I
probably threw up and quit more with
John the first six months of working out
than at any given time but my ability
not to want to be a quitter
continued to bring me back made me a
better athlete well you were you I
watched you in interviews and I watch
how you talk and I watch you know
whether it's you know calling certain
bodies and what they look like I'm gonna
tell you what you look like you you you
don't look that good you can't get
haters so you kind of are you know you
are the way you are and I also see you
in press conferences that you guys are
doing stole MP and you're kind of
sharing your opinion about the judge and
you're going back and forth with the
lady and you know she's the new judge
well the 7ja all this stuff so we'll go
through it out here in a minute
were you always a guy that didn't and
maybe you can correct me here didn't
necessarily just bow down to Authority
were you always like that was that a
part of your DNA or did you become that
you don't remember I mean I chose
bodybuilding it didn't choose me like I
didn't just stumble into it I I what you
saw is what I made you hear a lot of
athletes say I got my trainer and I got
my girlfriend and I got these people
John Brown and reduced me to body
willing I became the body butter so
whatever success I got it's just mine
whatever failures I've had I own it do
we all get introduced to something but
we don't necessarily get mentored
through all the process nobody was
walking through the contracts I didn't I
had to come up with my own valuation on
what I would charge for guest posing
what I would charge for an appearance a
seminar where I'm gonna determine where
I'm gonna fly what hotel understand
these are things you don't get taught
you know I mean now you have trainers
that are trying to help you out with
that kind of stuff at the time I came up
I chose to be a bodybuilder I put my art
up there I consider it an artistry and I
let the judges judge it when the contest
is over
you know I'm my own person there was no
one going to tell me what to do how to
eat how to train or what political game
I needed to play and I had the
favor of Joe Weider Joe Weider actually
liked the idea that I was vocal
independent and self-made and he made
sure that I stay true to that don't let
anyone take that away so my biggest
adversary like Mohammed had Howard who
sell yep
I had waned Amelia who happened to be
the president of the IFBB at the time I
could push Wayne's buttons at any given
moment because he can't I don't have a
contract with Wayne at a contract with
Joe Weider it doesn't get any higher
than that Joe's name is on my checks
that's the guy that I need to make sure
I have the relationship with and I
always had one with Joe Wayne I didn't
and I was very contentious with Wayne
because my argument wasn't for Shawn ray
when you saw me in the magazines
complaining and a lot of them said I was
bitching a lot of the body but all
Shawn's got something to say you're not
hearing me talk about me I'm talking
about fairness for salaries I'm talking
about the rotation of judges I'm talking
about the equity of athletes being paid
on stage my argument in my fight was
always for the betterment of the sport
which Joe could appreciate which is why
I never got a reduction in salary I
never got suspended I had a 17 year deal
with Joe his brother Ben liked the idea
that I was verbal and vocal and so they
liked it why do they like what they
liked the idea that I was a good-looking
black guy and they reminded me that I
was black showing bit so let me ask you
this who pays Wayne salary it was coming
from the weeders we did he work for Joe
Weider
so the magistration brain works for Joe
but Joe likes the fact that you're
calling out Wayne in public everybody
was on the show now mind you Ben ran the
IFBB and they hired Wayne to do all of
the pro pro body bone division yeah they
definitely didn't have a problem with me
confronting Wayne on issues and speaking
my mind they encouraged it stand up for
yourself and knowing I can have that
power I could go up to Wayne if I'm
saying the right if I'm in the right
place I can say whatever I wanted to
Wayne unfiltered and he and he had to
respect it I called him out in public
and changing the judges having
transparency was scoring that stuff
wasn't off limits but it was stuff that
needed to be talked about in public what
does the press conference for if not a
place for change
is where the chains needs to be
initiated and so my press
I took the the press conference to
another level most bodybuilders are
brain dead nothing to say let's just get
on with the show but if we're gonna have
a change this is where this conversation
needs to take place so Wayne wasn't a
guy that would call you up and say what
do you think we can do to make it better
for you athletes he would wait to the
press conference and none of the
athletes would have anything to say so
for me this is where we like the fuse so
you know they say an enemy of an enemy
is a friend and a friend of an enemy as
an enemy so who liked Wayne out of all
your competitors who had a good
relationship with Wayne maybe Paul delet
maybe I mean it's a very it's a very
small list of people about how about the
guy did Ronnie have a good relationship
with Wayne I don't think Ronnie had a
relationship with Wayne Wayne was more
of a dictator okay
his way or the highway he didn't ask you
what we're gonna do he told you what
we're gonna do and I thought if I didn't
like what he was saying I'd call him on
it because at the end of the day he has
to answer to Joe and bin and those were
the people I was dealing with now Wayne
doesn't own any of the brain no he was
unemployed he was an employee he worked
out of the New York office and and like
to dictate you know it's a power trip ER
and I knew that I was on the west coast
I could drive to Joe's office and talk
to Joe specifically to get things done
which is why Joe admired me because I
never left I didn't I didn't get my
check and disappear I made sure that he
knew who-who was given his money you
never had issues with Joe no never and
you never called him out you never had
any no because Joe you're not gonna find
anybody well you might find Frank Zane
you might find Robby Robinson there's a
few guys that feel that Joe took
advantage of them but Joe gave you
opportunity and if you weren't smart
enough and savvy enough to see where you
fit in then you can you can consider it
in hindsight that he's taking advantage
of you but look nobody knows who you are
without Joe Weider hmm you're in Joe's
magazine he's giving you a platform yeah
you got to determine your valuation on
what you're worth if you're getting
these protein ads and you're on the
cover of the magazine and in hindsight
you felt you should have been paid you
should put it in writing
so today who is Wayne today and who is
Joe today so I would have to say that
there is no Joe Weider there's no
replacing Joe I mean ami is running the
machine the pro-league Jim Mannion is
the Godfather of the industry he was
there under the tutelage of Joe and bin
everyone has an immense respect for Joe
for Jim Mannion everyone go
Jim Mannion runs a very tight ship
they've literally the NPC worldwide
started two years ago they have over 200
countries involved already
I think he's picked up the ball and ran
with it because clearly there's no
replacing Joe and there's no replacing
bin I know that people that are running
the industry now people like Dan Salomon
people like Angelica that's underneath
him helping out Tamriel Gundy coming on
strong with muscle contests I'm looking
at some of these people that I grew up
with there are now being elevated that
have the pedigree to keep the Machine
going some of the older guys are passing
the torch wayne de maiz out Joe and Ben
are gone
Jim Manya's brought his son his grandson
Tyler up into the mix we are in a very
good place right now I think we're in a
better place right now than we were
under the leadership of Wayne d'emilia
and Wayne de Mille was he helped found
the whole thing back with with Ben and
Joe but there's a different type of
distribution of power
there's nobody power tripping as a
matter of fact there's more opportunity
now to make a living out of the Olympia
brand than any other time and nodding so
I've heard a few people say oh you know
they're not they're not doing this from
you that for me they never did this is a
business like boxing you get from it
what you put into it there's no
contracts like there were before Joe
Weider used to have 15 30 athletes under
contract and we all were kind of told
what to do and when to do it now you
have this individual opportunity of
using the platform that if you can get
to Olympia you get this platform we have
the worldwide recognition
you have your own social media that you
can control your own brand if you do
well you're at the top of the food chain
you can command more money if you have
the ability to negotiate ability to
market ability to travel some of these
guys are at the top of the food chain
and they're not even leveraging half of
their opportunities most of these
bodybuilders aren't even guest posing
anymore
I
remember when Lee Haney won the Olympia
smear won the Olympia you can go to any
show in the country and find somebody
guest posing somewhere the majority
these top athletes don't guest post
because they don't get in shape they
don't want to stay in shape in the
offseason
I believe right now Phil Heath has seven
mr. Olympia Championships I know he had
some surgery that he overcame but I
don't believe on any level right now
he'll be on a guest posing stage a mr.
Olympia typically can get between five
and ten thousand dollars I believe Phil
it is at his peak was probably getting
fifteen thousand dollars in certain
countries I don't know any bodybuilder
from the 90s or even the 80s that would
turn their nose up at a $5,000 guest
posing fee you know you're talking to
minutes on stage to show the world an
80% physique Henderson that's what's
happening today what's happening today
these bodybuilders don't want to pose
because with social media you're posing
fat and out of shape it can ruin your
brand some athletes feel like you know
what I don't need to pose I'm I'm making
more money over here and there and they
don't do it acai green for example he
hasn't competed in three maybe four
years he's a guy that's out there making
good use of his time and his physique he
doesn't have to compete but yet he still
guest poses here and there I don't know
Brandon curry he's doing a very good job
as mr. Olympia representing I haven't
seen Shawn Rhoden I haven't seen Phil
Heath in probably two years guess posing
that would never happen when I was
coming up even Dorian Yates at 300 plus
pounds would guest pose and people could
see this is mr. Olympia Dorian each was
given yeah Dorian Yates when he was when
he was mr. Olympia you could go and see
drawing a chop pretty much something
known as a guy that you couldn't see his
body until he would show up and said
vivo would take place in April in
Germany and every year he'd be there one
of the biggest guys he wouldn't do so
much here in the States
he had an outlet over in New York his
good friends with Bev and Steve
Weinberger but yeah you can see Dorian
AIDS during his reign as mr. Olympia
guest posing you don't see it today so
let me ask you this are you now what is
your role now with mr. Olympia so I
don't really have a role you gotta
remember my first Olympia was 1988 I
have never missed that contest whether
as a competitor a sponsor or a
commentator or even a fan in so it's 32
years
Olimpia I've watched it grow to what it
is today
last year I was commentating I do the
world wide web broadcast which puts me
in a very unique place obviously with 14
years of experience of the Olympia in 32
years of not missing it I pretty much
know what I'm looking at I know who's
come up the ranks I see guys careers
come up and retire and I'm an analyst I
host the Arnold Classic amateur
competitions I'm an MC all around the
world for the NPC and the IFBB Pro
League the Olympia I continue to promote
I'm a missionary for bodybuilding just
like Ben wieder said he was I'm an
analyst so either I'm bringing sponsors
to the show I'm hosting hosting events
last year I hosted the reunion of past
Miss Olympia champions because now the
Miss Olympia is coming back very quietly
I might add it's coming back and people
need to pay attention to that cuz it's
been gone for about five or six years so
we had a reunion through wings of
strength and Jake wood and I hosted that
and we brought in Kiki IL m'a and all
these other women body builders that we
interviewed on the stage this year I'll
obviously be doing the colour
commentator and we break down all the
athletes but what I'm asking is is mr.
Olympia at all paying you for anything
are you a consultant of mr. Olympia I
get paid for my work that I do for the
Olympia and I promote the mr. Olympia
through my social media I got it so I'm
so the editor in chief of digital
muscles so I promote the the I to be Pro
League and the Olympians so for full
disclosure based on what you're saying
this is what I'm interpreting and call
me out if it's off and and tell me if
this makes sense or not so the the Shawn
ray of 94 okay the Shawn Ray of 96 99
whatever those years are 94 96 you know
what 94 96 so everybody knows what those
two years are yeah you know with the
left bicep man Shawn could be a two-time
he could be a four-time right I made a
few really and a lot of people would
agree with that including your haters
and it would also agree with that day
you couldn't be a two-time he could be a
four-time sure but but you were you were
very much of a vocal guy of how you felt
the judging was and all that was going
sir and you were almost pushing
a little bit of the brand of what things
they need to do for the politics
absolutely you sound like you're more
defending it today no I'm not defending
that what does last olympia you went to
the last I went to I don't know nine
years ago so I haven't missed any of
them so I've witnessed it I think Shawn
we know what America for Shawn Ray the
competitor was fighting for equal rights
for everyone I was like the Martin
Luther King a bodybuilding at that time
I wanted more pay more judging
transparency I wanted the order of
events changed it when I was doing it we
walked out in the symmetry round and
stood there me standing next to Dorian
Paul delet and Kevin Love Roni
I look like a Wallflower because I'm the
smallest of the bunch this is the first
look the judges would get I switch that
around to the first thing that the
judges would see and the fans is one
bodybuilder one at a time we walk out we
hit our eighth mandatory poses boom next
guy comes on so that the first thing
that they saw was us at our best we're
pumping up backstage we come out we flex
instead of stand there for 45 minutes
and deflate so we hit the eight
mandatories one at a time in the row you
can bring then road is bad you can make
your compared sure he's telling what you
saw because I come alive when I pose but
for many years I came out and I stood
there
so I argue I don't have the coal I pump
it up backstage I'm like this is the
biggest day of my life I'm gonna go
stand there for 45 minutes before you
ask we had that change I believe it was
like 97 98 it was it took a while but I
lobby for that then when I retired I
wanted to be the athletes rep because I
still was very passionate about some
things that weren't being done properly
the transparency the money distribution
and the judging situation and so I ran
for athletes rep and naturally waned
Amelia was the Acting President they
didn't want an athlete representative in
there he made me go and get the majority
of signatures from the registered
athletes which I got Craig Titus said I
forged his signature later on he
recanted and backed off of that but
that's a whole nother animal they were
being told that it wouldn't be good to
have an athletes representative well
who's telling them the people that are
running the industry they didn't want me
in there you know looking at what's
going on for the betterment of the
bodybuilders but nonetheless I became
the athletes rep when they changed the
time on a meeting that I was supposed to
attend
that's when I just quit for one I owed
three okay I quit that and then of
course I said you know what I moved on I
got married started my family suddenly
bodybuilding and the things that were
happening in bodybuilding weren't as
important but I was still representing
supplement companies still doing seminar
still making appearances but I didn't
really have the passion to defend the
athletes that are not willing to stick
their neck out for change
aka Phil Heath like because you under
tone you kind of talked about him
literally like five minutes ago right so
are you saying like somebody like Phil
he could have done more fun a lot of
those athletes could have done more for
themselves if you're doing well you're
mr. Olympia you're doing well without
having to rock the boat Ronnie Coleman
was in a press conference where he says
listen I was last I didn't complain I
was this I didn't complain why complain
well when you're getting the lion's
share of everything the six-year
contract with wieder on his first
Olympia got a six year contract right
you're getting that $100,000 payday and
you're getting the $10,000 guest posing
so yeah why complain but you can't turn
your eyes to the fact that the guy
that's in the Olympia that's number 11
representing Saudi Arabia is not gonna
get a dime when he leaves here but he's
on the poster he's representing a
country and he's got legions of fans and
they're selling that this guy should be
getting paid all of the guys showing up
for the Olympia I guarantee in the
Superbowl of this weekend everyone's
gonna walk away with money even the
losers just for making it to the Olympia
I was arguing for that for the mistral
so you so if if this was politics if
this was politics and you're running for
office you're for the majority it's not
necessarily more for the individual as
what you're saying so you're for the
little guy because based on what you
said Ronnie he had eight in a run you
went to Ronnie you went Dorian you went
to well hey me Dorian and Ronnie right
we went through these big three guys the
face if those guys are not around 22
years of mr. Olympia for weight 22
consecutive years of mr. Olympia Ronnie
had a Lee Haney had a Andorian had y8
during my 14 year pro career I came
probably five years too late a lot of
people think I'm sour grapes but let me
tell you something I had one of the best
colorful careers of not winning a show
and still being inducted into the
bodybuilding Hall of Fame all at five
foot seven 210 pounds I got nothing to
complain about I don't think anybody
takes that away from well a lot of
people think with social media you hear
a lot of opinions people think I'm sour
grape said I didn't be Doren nobody be
durian I mean Mohammed bin Aziza the
shortest guy up there beat him in his
rookie year but outside of me no one
else beat door and I was in the
conversation argumentatively to beat
Dorian Yates but I didn't hear the same
argument for Kevin Love Ronan to beat
Dorian Yates I didn't hear that flex
wheeler should've beat or hates the
controversy was like 94 96 so 97 Nasir a
couple of times Dorian could have been
beat it's left for debate but I sleep
well at night
I I didn't have to not it doesn't take
anything away from my career that I
didn't win the mr. Olympia is what I'm
saying I think because I'm healthy
because I didn't tear my bicep because I
didn't lose my leg because I didn't wind
up in a wheelchair doesn't make me any
smarter than those bodybuilders they did
what they had to do but I was always
aware of the finish line I wanted to be
healthy I wanted to be wealthy and I
wanted to be well-traveled I got all of
those things I didn't get the standout
trophy but I don't lose any sleep over
that so so so 32 years 88 to 2020 you've
never mr. Olympia and you've never
missed the Arnold Classic since the
first one you will never missed why
absence oh you're your gamer you you're
you're not a company man that's what I
want to make clear because you're you
realize no you're a little bit hold on
you were alluding to the fact that am i
working I think I'm working I'm carrying
on the torch that Joe and Ben have I
worked for Muscle & Fitness last year
promoting the mr. Olympia which is in
their wheelhouse promoting it in what
way trying to get more visibility but
then I'm also a witness to what's
happening
I witnessed the largest payout in the
history of the game last year they
raised the prize money for the missile
all the Miss Olympia the physique
classic physique
every division got a raise and the mr.
Olympia is $400,000 so I can't complain
about the prize money if I see any more
money coming in yeah I'd like it not to
go to the top I like it to feed down to
the bottom in working with somebody like
dan who I could walk into Dan's office
is a Dan we got to do something for the
people outside the top 10 because while
they're not winning they're still
lending credence and credibility
to this show we got to pick up the back
end monetarily don't give the winner
more money because $400,000 is a pretty
big payday but it's also a platform to
go out and do other things develop
sponsorship don't give to one or more
money it's well you know if you want to
make it a winner-take-all then why are
we gonna have 20 people competing for
the mr. Olympia title you know if it's a
winner-take-all then what are we doing
with these other guys we want to it has
to be more inclusive if you're going to
get people coming to that competition
you think capitalism works it does but
why have so many shows to qualify for
the Olympia your capital is I don't want
to go to the show and just watch Brandon
Currie stand up there by himself no I'm
not saying that I don't I don't not
saying that at all
but do you believe countless works okay
you know capitalism works and capitalism
typically works because there's a what
there's a guy that's you know way ahead
that pisses off the rest of the guys
sure and those guys are willing to go
out there and do more typically if you
have one person well no it's still a
subjective sport of opinion like you
said listen I got a box you get it takes
last in the mr. Olympia may not look
like mr. Olympia but does just as much
work listen I mean look look okay if
that's the case let me just get into
this part I'll play this video for you
because I actually agree with what you
say here and I want to go into this next
so if if Paul you want to come around
here okay this is one of the things I
want to do it to see what you'll say
about this and you know this you brought
this up a couple times you know which
one this is
nobody's asked the question out of those
22 judges how many judges judges us last
year that will be judging us this year
there's gonna be 11
leave this show Saturday night nothing
in their pocket I mean somebody needs a
dress and Ronnie's like I complain he
gets the check every year so who you
here frontin here for me but certainly
it is 2001 and I'm still being judged by
the same people there are enough people
out there where the guy maybe he's got
to recruit new judges we need new
opinions to get new gluts in
bodybuilding we're not gonna continue
and then your buddy Ronnie responds with
you said right now you yourself so is
this a purpose what you said in 1992
maybe complaining already get you
nowhere which is by the way this is
great for the sport absolutely this is
great or does it like Ronnie Coleman I
mean that that is classic and typical
Ronnie Coleman mind you here's the guy
that came from a very educated
background right didn't get into
bodybuilding for the money and if they
took the prize money away Ronnie Coleman
would probably be the only one competing
for the mr. Olympia title I wouldn't do
it for free this is a business and I
think that if you're gonna leverage
other countries if you're gonna leverage
other countries and you're going to
include Iran or you're gonna clue
Germany or England
it's got to be palatable or we're gonna
lose that international flavor because
you're gonna run into a guy like him
Ronnie or Phil it can run off with the
title for six or seven or eight more
years and we're gonna wind up with a
show that nobody wants to attend because
it's a foregone conclusion so let me
tell you let me tell you why I played
this right now for you what led me to
want it to play the video now you said
bodybuilding is a very subjective sport
right like you know how in a your
basketball guy Jordan wouldn't win an
MVP they're like give me a break
you got to give it to Barkley right you
got to give it to a team or whatever
they given it to us everybody knows
who's the MVP Jordan could have won MVP
twelve years in a row if you think about
it right and LeBron could have won way
more than the four that he has or some
of these guys that are playing Shaq
could have been a Kobe could add
sometimes they do that and it's politics
how do you measure MEP you can't measure
MVP it's also subjective right there's
somebody that's voting for the judging
from 88 to today okay you make a very
very good point nothing is more annoying
than me putting my body through what I'm
putting through to get it to where it's
at today and I have to sit there and
hear judges make a decision on my body
and they may not know necessarily if
they're judging a property or not how
much have you seen judging improve from
88 to where we are today what's been the
evolution I mean you gotta remember I
retired because the judging wasn't
changing people said why did I walk away
35 36 years old you could have still
gone six more years that was my final
salvo after that contest I think you
heard
you say somewhere in there don't worry
I've done my homework I'm not afraid of
anybody because I knew they couldn't
take what I do away I'm gonna put it on
display and the fans are gonna see it
right but I didn't want to get back up
in front of those judges again and be a
part of the Ronnie Coleman retirement
party for years after I retired because
they say he's just too big I mean if
that's what bodybuilding was coming to
and I think that's why leave the Prada
walked away we just didn't carry the
size well then what am i doing I mean I
have other things in life I want to
achieve I have other things to do with
my time then beat myself up in a gym and
abuse my body because that's what
bodybuilding is you beaten hell out
yourself these judges weren't changing
and going away anytime soon
now I'm I'm 19 years removed from that
press conference I'm in a different
space I don't go to a show and analyze
how the judges are doing it when I take
my role as an analyst I see it the way
Shawn Ray sees it I put it in the
microphone for the world to hear and
disseminate the judges are still going
to make their decisions now before Phil
Heath got through with his prejudging I
said Shawn Rhoden was probably gonna win
that contest before Brandon curry
finished his prejudging I said we're
probably looking at a new mr. Olympia in
Brandon Currie that's a big statement
when you have Phil Heath who has seven
Olympia titles you just gotta assume it
said he can walk in and win the show I
watched it with Ronnie Coleman said I
watch wrong today did you say he was
gonna win each one when you saw him Phil
yeah no Phil Phil's very first Pro win
was a Shawn Ray classic in Colorado I'm
not sure if you know that but when we
saw that we knew he was something
special
Jay Cutler acknowledges there were some
things but I think Phil bought into that
knowing he was something special he was
brought along promptly he came up the
ranks fourth fourth or fifth his first
Olympia second and then he ultimately
did what he was gonna do but we you can
see genetics there's no denying it now
it just comes down to work ethic Phil
had all of those intangibles coming from
a background of basketball Brandon
Currie not so much Shawn Rhoden is laid
back not so much he had the genetics but
you just know didn't know if you had the
work ethic but you could see that Shawn
won that competition not because he's a
better bodybuilder but because Phil was
clearly off now I've heard a lot of
people say Phil being off is still
better than Shawn Rhoden the judges did
the right thing because I wish they
would have done that in my era because
probably would had several other mr.
Lampe is like Kevin Love Roni or flex
wheeler but the judges get comfortable
with the same thing when they're people
that they are friends with they're
comfortable with and that they're used
to this same group of judges likes
chocolate this year they're gonna like
chocolate next year they're gonna like
chocolate the next year it's hard to
break down that barrier unless you start
throwing in some different judges in
there and they we're not doing that are
they doing it now I don't know because I
don't really I don't have a horse in
that race since I know a little bit more
come on say my role is not to analyze
who the judging panel you're a voice
through you're not a regular I am an
analyst and there is a difference at the
time I became the athletes rep and I
defended the athletes in this time where
the athletes did not want to be defended
as a matter of fact Craig said that I
forged his signature and that's a lot
because I didn't have to do that and I
was voted the athletes rep and I quit
that job I had the power right here and
I quit it because of how it was being
run under Wayne d'emilia now I can say
what I want to say on based on what I'm
looking at I'm not looking at it and
through the eyes of a judge my vote
doesn't count it's my opinion and like
Stephen a Smith I'm entitled to my
opinion and I put it out there for the
world to decide but the last three last
four Olympia's I was spot on including
with hottie to pin and for that for that
matter coming into the Arnold Classic I
think Josh and arcuate wants to beat me
up because I said he you know he had
some head surgery and I said this is
probably not what he should be doing
right now regardless of how he looks
I had a hood surgery I probably wouldn't
want to be bodybuilding at least take a
year off
what's the beat me up as a result of
that criticism surgery leave a junior I
don't have him in my top six going into
the Arnold Classic so now I'm a whiny
[ __ ] I mean I can't please the athlete
but I have the ability to speak my
opinion my opinion is not a vote on the
judging panel I don't think that's the
quote so you said Steven Naismith I'm
like Steven Naismith I'm an analyst yes
who pays you I get paid by numerous
sources I'm a sponsored endorser of
business rolling up your pay no I do not
get paid by the mr. Olympia except for a
my I never got a check from ami I got a
check from Muscle & Fitness last year
okay when I was writing for muscle
fitness I write for digital muscle I'm
an editor regional and digital muscle is
the broadcast of the mr. Olympia weekend
so Jake
would signs my check I didn't get a
check from is it linked to mr. Olaf II
or no no Digital muscle prior to digital
muscle you had I herb doing the
worldwide broadcast prior to that you
had bodybuilding.com I worked for those
guys I would get much just like the
Arnall classic I get my check from Bob
Lorimer when I emcee the competition
yeah when the Olympia rolls around my
check will come from the digital muscle
from doing the web broadcast last year
it came from muscle fitness so there's
no NPC IFBB signature on any of my
checks I get paid by my sponsors which
is real leader USA a gym equipment out
of China s4 swatches I'm a spokesperson
for proton USA and I represent a
clothing line of mints clothing line leo
reveille so none of the money that I
generate comes from the infrastructure
of the industry this capitalism thing
we're talking about it all comes from
the pedigree that I built up as an
olympian what was I'm all over the world
business yeah but that's the platform
they give you right so in that platform
we I heard you say something like what
does the Olympia doing for you athletes
they don't owe us anything it's just
like boxing like if you're busted
well listen we're not a union hold on
this is not the NFL and it's not the NBA
and we don't pretend that you know when
we had Joe Weider it was a one-stop shop
everyone in the early 90s I was part of
it I was on that wieder payroll and we
were the Machine flex magazine muscle
fitness guy that's gone wieder was
bought by ami now all you have are your
supplements are your clothing lines or
your own individual things that your
entrepreneurial skills sure I develop
yeah
there is no Federation or chat going to
anybody doesn't know the IFBB doesn't
write a check to anyone except for the
winners of the pro competitions they're
not writing I don't get a monthly check
because I'm a member of the pro league I
I don't think I'm debating the part that
Phil ought to be doing more stuff to go
make money I don't I don't think I'm
debating I don't we're not off there so
we're not off and he's working on that
right now he's got a lot of good things
that he's working on the side projects
but Olympia platform has provided right
and Kai greens been able to monetize it
probably more than any other bodybuilder
in the last five years a lot of - Jay
Cutler okay Jay Cutler is a machine he
knows how to make money and he's a smart
guy but but I'm bringing this up to you
from a different standpoint
you're saying you know what is mr. Olaf
you're doing for you okay
I'm saying it cuz I've said it on
multiple videos what is my stroller if
your brand doing for you great I'm not
saying it from the standpoint of hey you
know let's make College free let's do
this free let's take care of your bills
let's pay I'm not saying that it's not
what I'm saying to you
what I am saying is there's got to be
somebody that sits there and says like a
Joe Weider you're talking about like a
Stein burner yeah
like a Jerry Buss like a you know these
names that I mentioned alright crafts
like these guys are shown and say hey
let's go do something I don't think you
got to talk to this guy I know this
person over here I want to introduce you
to this guy when I can do see to that
guy I would want to have my number one
become so flippin successful that the
next twenty two-year-old wants to have
that life no I'm 100% with you however
you're absolutely right there's there's
none of that so what's the solution for
that you're Nam you're 32 years
absolutely and I brought that up before
talking with Dan Salomon who's at the
top of the Olympia chain because it
seems like when you have the changing of
the gaurd when you do the same thing you
wind up with the same results the best
thing that could have happened for the
Olympia is that they had a changing of
the guard they brought in some new new
people so with Dan who is of the same
ilk as me he's got this pedigree with
the pro bodybuilding weekly he was the
former editor of the digital muscle he's
now running the the mr. Olympia weekend
and putting all these different people
in play to kind of build it back up last
year we had Mark Wahlberg as ambassador
this year we have Shaquille O'Neal he's
not the guy okay because he doesn't have
these you know that he knows that
because his role is to make sure that
when the athletes wind up at the Super
Bowl of bodybuilding they get what they
want which is why I was telling you it's
got to have the trickle-down effect with
the guys that are coming from these
other countries wherever there have come
from Japan China they need to get some
reward in order to keep coming back to
Olympia we don't have that godfather if
I were looking for that Godfather I look
towards Jim Mannion but that's never
been his role he's he's the president of
the NPC and now the expanded NPC
worldwide his grandson Tyler's a little
bit too young 25 26 years old he's not
the guy there is no replacing Joe and
bin because you got to consider who's
dedicated to this that way
but who is but let me explain I've been
around I know everybody
with I don't know the world that if
there is or there isn't but I will I
will give you perfect perspective okay
okay oh oh you know Paul Chris Paul
leaves and goes to the Clippers okay
there they're not working out Donald
sterling he leaves he stays next guy
comes built an organization you know doc
becomes president GM they started
winning good things are happening and
players want to go there then next you
know qui Leonard and Paul George decide
to go over there okay so so the the
Clippers is an organization it was owned
by a different person and another guy
came in and decided to take you to a
different level players want to play
form right hey I got contacts at
Microsoft I got contacts over here I got
contacts over here and he loves the game
he's a Cuban look at what Mark Cuban did
a very classy move he made this last
week
Kobe never played for what he called it
the Mavericks right what does he do he
retires a jersey number 24
perhaps players love playing for this
guy Dirk Nowitzki never wanted to go
anywhere else now you got the porzingis
and you got this new kid leuco to me one
of the most exciting players in the
league wants to play form yeah and some
of the team's people don't want to play
for the owner yeah and then and then you
look at some of the other like boxing
and you look at the MMA I don't know if
you follow UF's I do look at they know
why there was pride if you remember MMA
15 years ago it wasn't just UFC right it
was a few other things and you were kind
of watching this they would let you need
a guy in to face and USC didn't and then
they started doing some things and then
he came out with a show called the what
was a show called is that a fighter
Ultimate Fighter next thing you know
were like oh this is kind of cool
they're living in the same place they're
getting into fights
so take alternate fight around you mean
to tell me you FC would be as big as
today so all I'm saying is all I'm
saying is if somebody if somebody is
working on finding a way to turn Shaun
rain to hero to turn Brandon Currie into
hero above and beyond what fill what you
would brand and what all these other
guys need to do on their own right if
somebody does that you're just giving me
a bigger full of exposure no you're
right that's what I'm trying to not
throwing anybody under the bag eyes
don't see that happening our sport is
not at that level we are is still a cult
sport we're not the US
we don't have billions of dollars of
value either 15 years ago no and you're
talking about people remember Joe Weider
started at 15 he died at 93 and he
devoted his life to this we don't have
anybody with that type of pedigree
pulling the strings are running the
industry we have some some glimpses of
people that have the familiarity we're
living in a time now where the athlete
can control the way they look and how
they're perceived through their own
digital media when I was with Joe Weider
I couldn't talk to another magazine
because he owned me exclusively you
wouldn't read a Sean ray article that I
gave you that would have to come through
muscle fitness and flex because I
couldn't do it with iron man and muscle
development they weren't paying me I was
paid to exclusively appear there now
what you're finding is that yeah the
magazine's may not be what they were but
there's a lot of athletes that they will
only get the news on their feed if
you're not following them on Instagram
or on their Facebook you're not gonna
find out about it they they won't do the
business of bodybuilding outside of
their own social media getting them to
come to a podcast with you that might be
outside the scope of if they have their
own podcast
you know what I'm saying they want you
on their social media it's numbers
because then I can sell it I can have
sell advertising there's nobody and we
need that I would love that if we had
some school of thought for example one
of our body builders got in trouble and
I think a lot of the trouble that he got
into is there was no mentorship you know
you come to the Lakers you're gonna meet
Magic Johnson you would have met Kobe
Bryant and it kind of would have showed
you the way around the locker room and
how business is done as a as a young raw
talent you come in to pro bodybuilding
you got the best genetics and you're the
future mr. Olympia there's no one
telling you how to be mr. Olympia it's
it's baptism by fire and you can wind up
in a lot of hot places like one of our
Olympia champions ultimately did because
probably didn't have the right
mentorship do we need that yeah is there
someone out there that I can point a
finger to in all of my years there's no
one that is out there that's in that
position to take that on I mean it
really is the wild wild west and
bodybuilding because you can't go to
Arnold Arnold's you know these seventies
got a lot of things going on it's not
his passion like Joe's Joe Joe had that
passion and that passion is gone and now
we don't have anybody like that so this
being a very individualized sport you
got to make
of it what you can and you take from it
what you will Jake has no these are
either yeah no I mean we're it's such an
individual business independent
contracting business that J is all about
J and can you play no know why he did
everything he had to do and he probably
doesn't even have the relationships with
the bodybuilders today that he had when
he was competing whose fault is that
dough
I think we're disjointed now because of
so yeah but what but no I don't think
it's social media because social media
is also brought a lot of people together
shanties think about it social medias
also brought a lot of people together
you go bats also divided a lot of people
because you get blocked and deleted and
you say the wrong thing you put up the
wrong I put up a picture of me and
Dorian Yates standing relax and I
actually look better than him and not a
bunch of his fans come on here block the
leap box for him and that shows you know
some of the people that probably came
and said good things about you you take
Twitter out the current president's not
president right you take Facebook and
YouTube Barack Obama's not a two-term
senator you know you take social media
out there's a little tool there it's so
powerful to it's how you use the tool
people can say stuff they want to say
about weapons share about a lot of
different TVs for some other guys look
at the TV look at Elvis Presley the way
he's moving his hips our girls are gonna
have sex with everybody now are you
gonna do I know I have a 40 year old
dancer soul singer you know these things
go but you know you sit down you some of
the words it's how do you use the great
equalizer of social media to me I think
social media is a big advantage to mr.
Olympia if they do it problem well when
you start at leats the athletes are so
divided so dispersed and so
individualized them together well I mean
when you start bringing them together
everybody wants to be paid for their
time right so if I'm working for you put
me on the payroll that's pretty much the
attitude of a lot of if I brought all of
you guys to get I'm not telling you I'm
gonna put you on the payroll here's what
I would say listen guys let's look at
the model put parallels on models
together right what's the other model
UFC let's look at the UFC model right
UFC model took viewers away from boxing
yeah there are people that followed
boxing that became UFC fans right I'm
one of us oh yeah me too they pulled
away from it right now boxing there is
no Don King today their biggest promoter
today is Mayweather it ain't even
anybody that's Bob you know right just
those promoters on that wall okay so if
I bring you guys in a soda some guys
here
what we want to do what do you want to
do this is our numbers here's what we
did
here's our revenues this is pay-per-view
here's how much we sold to you here's
how much we sold you here's how much we
sold here yeah if there is a way for us
to get the numbers here this is what we
could do I can't pay you salary right I
can't pay the numbers now here's what
happens next
all of a sudden added its 15 people that
are in there what do eight of them do
they say screw you I don't want to do it
you pay me now don't do anything
no probably told you understand we hope
you can help us right out of the seven
that's in 3/4 of them say okay let's do
something about this then we run you're
not expecting to get everybody you're
not ever gonna get it but you still have
that you're coming from a place where
the bodybuilders think there's something
wrong and I'm telling you to a to a man
they're in it for themselves I mean to
try to bring that unity together I mean
you got to be talking about the bottom
feeders that are getting absolutely
nothing because most these guys have
found a way to monetize their social
media they pick and choose when they
want to compete their trainers tell them
when they can and cannot compete so
we're still on this diverse road to
nowhere in terms of unity there is no
unification because again you don't have
athlete representation but what I will
say and this is not a company man not
missing the olympian 32 years it's
bigger than it's ever been the prize
money is in terms of attendance in the
terms of prize money in terms of
participation and now they're adding
another division or attendees and
absolutely the more people come in other
than 32 years ago I like to invite you
this year just so you can see it I was
there I mind you I'm there in this
packed arena sold out
standing room only and people were still
trying to get tickets on the 11th hour
at the finals and that's because I think
they realized there's number one gonna
be a new mr. Olympia but am I still has
the publicity machine of their you know
magazines and publications that they
have they've reached out across the
board with like Mark Wahlberg and other
big personalities I love a love that
move that they're taken with that it was
actually rocked and Mark and I'll check
yeah and and so when people are talking
about the Olympia maybe rivaled by Shaq
let me just put in perspective by the
rock that's an addition that's not a
competition the Olympia is this the
athletic con is going to be that and
they're working in concert with each
other all under the umbrella
the ifbb pro league there hasn't been a
bigger mr. Olympia contest that was
attended then last year the prize money
has never been bigger than last year so
when people say it's it's diminishing
you got to remember I think the mr.
Olympia the body bowling side may not be
as competitive but it was a full lineup
you were missing who big Rami you're
missing Phil Heath and you're missing
Shawn Road and you're missing Kai green
and yet that's still a lot that was a
lot of people missing all the arguing
without LeBron without John and it was
and it was still a sellout and guess
what the people still showed up for the
show so we didn't need them
and what I'm saying and that was Dan
Solomon's first run at promoting the
show what happens 2 to 3 years down the
road when there's other things added
like I said the Miss Olympia is being
added back in the classic physique seems
to be taking on a life of its own you've
got James flex Lewis coming back to do
the open after winning 7 to 12 titles
that's gonna make that open division
interesting hotty cupid's coming back he
was third a lot of people had him even
over William Bonin there's a challenge
that if he gets the visa but it's that's
anticipation that people can build upon
a competition for not to mention there's
still the X Factor does Philly's come
back or not
people are waiting he hasn't said yes or
no but I tell you what this is a contest
that you had he looks like you could you
have to plan in advance you have to plan
in advance but someone needs to call and
say what do we need to do to get you
back Phil so Phil no no no someone from
the brand needs to call Phil and say
what do we listen I'm gonna I'll tell it
like it is I love Phil yeah the brand is
doing just fine
they don't need mister they don't need
si the Olympia does not need Phil Heath
to make the mr. life I'm not saying that
of course it doesn't how that still has
to make himself of it the Olympia last
year by the way let me give you no did
Phil go to the Olympia last year did
Phil what did Phil go to the Olympia car
I don't think you do I don't think he
did either I can tell you that
unequivocally if I was in an Olympia as
many times as he was and I watched
everyone he was in from fifth place to
second place to the seven-year first
Olympians in the last one the runner up
he should have been the one handing the
trophy to the guy I mean Phil you should
have called them Phil I don't know that
anybody has it's like but
but you getbut shuttle Camille who does
this say that they didn't call her okay
let's just say let's just say they did
not okay
that's how passionate I'm like I didn't
want it but I never miss it how can he
sit at home and watch the competition
that made him who he is I mean he must
add something wrong but you you're quick
to forget with the fact that you were
calling out judges event after event
after day and I never missed a contest
in 32 years but but I understand that
were you know complete different
position than he is this is a guy that I
know but he as mr. Olympia you would
think that as mr. Olympia seven times
and we think that the brand would be
reaching out to say we're grateful for
you you know so you know someone did
call him to find out whether or not he
was coming he had other things to do you
got to know the whole scope of the story
so - it was fill waiting for the mr.
Olympia to fly a private jet out for him
to come in since I'm not you're
sensitive in terms of what what do you
mean you're kind of course you're gonna
be sensitive a crazy competitor that
pays attention to the details to the
body your sensor because you're
perfectionist I'm not I don't have a
horse in the race
I don't know but but anybody anybody
that competes at the highest level one
of their gifts they have is they're a
little bit more sensitive to details and
others work other people I'm not saying
I get side of your you're weaker since
I'm actually using it as a compliment
yeah I got guys in there tomorrow I'm
doing my annual virtual gala okay
there's a me eight thousand people
watching okay yesterday we just send out
nearly ten thousand 1099 checks around
the nation 49 says we got insurance
agents so I'm sending these checks to
people I did my convention six months
ago at Mirage we have President Bush
sure Kobe Bryant there we had Jordan
Peters and all these guys at the event
we're doing the next one at enemy MGM
Grand Arena was shut down the place for
four days we're hosting it especially
people gonna be at this event right
these guys are work who work their asses
off they sell on Saturdays they sell on
Sundays they're running opponents on
Saturday night they're running that
additional appointment on Friday night
while him and you know husband and wife
can go have dinner they choose to go do
another sale to sell an annuity or sell
another insurance policy and protect
another family 11 o'clock you're done
you come home you can't go watch a movie
you're tired he goes to sleep
boom the next day right this is stuff
that you gotta do mm-hmm this is stuff
you got to do yeah and one of the things
I told our guys here when we started
company and I've said this to them every
month when I do my staff meeting very
important here I've said it every month
this sales team is king
I do specific training shot to tell him
how to speak to lions right today we
give a girl a promotion she's gonna have
a job she's gonna be doing something
that's very important you got promotion
today I had a 45-minute meeting with her
and her smart CEO was sitting to all
these people were sitting and I said
listen do you know how to speak to lions
and we went through it I said here's
what you got to realize about lions
they're wired differently right they're
demanding their emotional they're
sensitive I am upset yeah
you can't I can't sit there and say oh
you're upset at me it's your fault yeah
I can I can understand the part if a guy
is lazy if a guy goes and does ecstasy
every night and right after a show he
goes and hooks up with six girls and is
just partying and that's all he cares
about and he's using bodybuilding as a
form to be able to rack up more girls
and all this but that's not this guy yes
I said guys so all I'm saying is all I'm
saying is if a if a sh an array of oh
three or oh one one was it was oh one if
a shine ray is ticked off and you're
kind of pissed off and you're a
demanding guy you're a sensitive guy
you're annoyed you're sinner of course
there's a part of it that you're talking
about the other guys but of course a big
part of it is also you want to be masked
or limp you've given since 1988 to it
all I'm saying is the brand cannot say
we're bigger than a seven-time is
strolling even though it's right I'm not
saying that they said that what I'm what
I'm saying from my cheap seat okay the
Olympia will go on whether you have a
seven-time Olympia sitting in the front
row or sitting at home no it's not
arrogant what I'm saying is there's
always been an open door policy
if mr. Olympia is waiting for the
Federation who doesn't write him a check
he was with wieder
or yeah he was sponsored by Weiner we
didn't let him go and he won a couple
Olympia's after he his wieder contract
was over if you're waiting for a phone
call for an invitation to a contest of
that magnitude when you actually know
the promoter and you can say hey I need
five tickets I need 10 tickets I want to
have a booth all of that stuff
I can't sit at home away from my phone
to ring you got to be proactive are you
kidding me then Olympia was bigger and
better than it's ever been
even though Phil wasn't there all I'm
saying is it's bigger than any
bodybuilder the car it's an institution
I don't dispute that let's say you're
right let's say you're right let's say
you're right the Colin Kaepernick go
back to the ship with Colin Kaepernick
when he knelt and he said what he said
and then everybody's like oh my gosh
there's another guy there's another guy
there's another guy domino effect okay
domino effect you know who I bling on
the entire situation
guess what learn on the entire story
from day one I blame one guy only one
guy blame guess who it is
Goodell go tell who else you gonna blame
listen if the guy is trying to make a
statement immediately look I don't know
if there was a statement being made I
feel not going to the Olympia he might
add in numerous the reasons why you
don't know what I'm saying and I would
call is not even the best guy yeah he's
not only personally I think the mr.
Olympia should have that entire front
row for all of the past mr. Olympia to
beat it that's my opinion if you're only
knee above that but I agree with that I
would go a little bit about that but for
me I think I think to say I think to say
the brand will never be bigger or the
brand will and one of my guys I was
talking he makes about he makes a good
$600,000 your income makes good income
decent income he's not my best top five
guys top ten guys but he's one of the
guys that's doing pretty good and I sat
down with him one day and I said listen
I want you to realize this he says
what's that I said you walk around as if
your block of business is gonna pay you
for the rest of your life I say you
walking around like you're bigger than
circuits sitting in Kmart keep in mind
Circuit City and Kmart went out of
business they got arrogant and cocky and
Blockbuster Circuit City and Kmart's all
bigger than you are you're a nobody
compared to those companies right what's
the point if boxing gets cocky
thinking they're not gonna lose eyeballs
on UFC Dana White is gonna come and take
it over so to say that Iraq is
supplementing a you know if and by the
way my worry wouldn't even become a
constant comment is complementing I
don't even think Iraq is the one that
would be my concern if Danny by any
chance gets an itch to want to really go
up Danny can pull the strings and do
whatever she wants Danny Garcia and by
the way she's works very closely with
the IP pro-league I mind all of that
sterno exists
because they do their job they do and
that's good for everybody and for me for
me I would like nothing more but to see
the mr. Olympia brand get even big
bigger than what it is today so by the
way one of the questions asked I didn't
get the answer of description of what
you were gonna say to it
are you more it has the system and
judging change between now versus oh one
versus 88 you know I can't tell because
we're judging totally different bodies
you know when I was competing you had
the top six for Hall of Fame body was
there all the Hall of Fame all of them I
heard you make a couple of comparisons
will do that I think you I think you
know what bran is in because he has an
Olympian right so he's in that elite 15
Dexter's in because he won in 2008 and
is the winningest pro bodybuilder ever
I mean fills in I mean it's conquering a
Hall of Fame bodybuilder he won't you
got to first runner ups at the Olympia 3
first runner ups it didn't be a couple
of on a classic there might be an
argument he's better than Eli Manning
right there's a stronger argument for
Kai green to be in the bodybuilding Hall
of Fame but the lineup that we're
judging now is the judging with
different criteria man I mean so I don't
know how the judges are judging I don't
it's not something that I would want to
be a part of in terms of judging oh but
I think it's something that you ought to
put a give you opinion on because you
have a history of doing that and if the
concern is really the younger guys I
think you ought to do a little bit more
due diligence and see how things don't
go and I'll give you an idea why I think
that is because ok you look at that
video I don't know how long it's like 47
minutes that's a good it's it's a good
amount to watch and you guys are going
back and forth back and forth the only
one they ever sold online they saw the
DVD
it's phenomenal by the way I think this
is very good for to spoil her Kevin said
he said something's wrong Ronnie when
everyone's booing so nobody wants to see
it mr. Olympia boos right I think you
were onto something I think you were
onto something because if I'm gonna give
my life to it I want to do it there's no
there's gonna be a way that I'm being
judged that's fair yeah
for example if I go to court and I'm
going to the jury is going to come and
go up and judge me the jury cannot be a
friend the jury
I cannot have dinner together right
that's what we were up a so that's what
I'm saying how much does it change I
don't know that they I don't know that
those judges have that same type of
relationship that we had back then you
don't think or you don't I don't know
okay because I'm not invested in it
seriously I'm 19 years removed I know
some of the judges but I don't know all
of the judges it's changed when involved
I'm not as passionate or as close to it
because it doesn't directly affect me
when I was up there on that press
conference I was being directly affected
by continuous decisions to have the same
staff of judges who were friends with
notorious friends with Ronnie Coleman
the girl I was argument with is Ronnie
Coleman's friend Dorian Yates his good
friend was with Steve Weinberger I think
the bigger issue for these athletes is
is that they are not I don't think
there's enough personalities out there
back then
phlex had his own swag I had my own swag
Dorian however invisible he was had his
but we all had our own personalities
Kevin too and now it's just kind of like
there's there's nothing really there
when Shawn Rhoden won the Miss mr.
Olympia contest there was really nothing
- there was no groundswell of support
after he wanted because you just didn't
see the guy anywhere and I don't know if
that's but with the magazine demise or
whatnot but there's just not very many
personalities kai green still has a very
colorful personality that he's able to
capitalize on he's got a great
personality and that personality can
take him a lot of places what Brandon
Curry's doing a little bit of his is in
different ways he's opening his third
gym I believe he's talking to schools
he's traveling around he's an ambassador
he's doing everything right as mr.
Olympia but this coming Olympia is gonna
be very interesting I'm actually curious
about I had a meeting with some people
from the mr. Olympia organization about
possibly doing something and showing up
so you know it depends on how the
schedule will look like I may be
attending myself it's a different animal
yeah I want you're there and you're just
analyzing it through I'm very curious
yeah I'm very curious so let me ask you
now let's talk about a complete
different thing transitioning more into
the
health aspect the judging part for me I
was talking to Ron for muscular
development I said you know the concerns
that you have when you see these guys
that are very big okay you know like all
of us um one day you're getting picture
of Greg Kovacs this guy is bench
pressing you know 700 pounds 26 inch
guns and we don't see that today you
don't see that today but that would
never win the great Kovacs is not gonna
loose it just that it didn't win then I
don't know how yes of course of course
but point I'm making to you is 197 218
okay that is a 21 pound difference in
how many years of competition 14 that's
a long time to go from 197 to 218 we're
typically that's not the case the
increase is a lot more than 197
flexibility flex wheeler was 216 pounds
in the 93 Arnold Classic where a lot of
people thought it was his best and only
a couple short years later with the
arrival of Dorian eights he was
competing at well over 245 okay he
wasn't a better version of flex wheeler
perfect so and he had all the genetics
so so where I'm going with this as a
part of it is what judging gives points
for what judging gives the additional
upper advantage for right okay so now
this leads me to the topic of drugs and
steroids and gh and all that other stuff
okay if you and I don't know if you did
but based on some of the research I did
did you and Chad Nichols ever do
anything together absolutely not okay so
so so because I know this stuff out of
work into me bro okay so even if he did
get close to you you would have never
been tried as he tried to do in 1996 I
went to guest post for him took me to
dinner and he asked me if I needed any
help
I just got second place to Dorian AIDS
no I don't need your help I don't even
know you first of all and I've done it
all myself and I think that's where we
started to butt heads i flatly refused
any help from him and then he went on to
say a few years later that if I had his
help maybe I could have been mr. Olympia
which is nonsense because of course you
had NASA in 97 and flex wheeler in Kevin
Boronia that were getting second places
towards the end but Chad's got blood all
over his hands man
I mean Ronnie Coleman will defend him to
the ninth degree but he was in that
bathtub near death in 2001 at the
direction of Chad Nichols who's not a
doctor by the way
there's at least five deaths Don
Youngblood NASA relson body Dallas
McCarver and a few other people that
he's had his relationships with as a
bodybuilding coach that are dead and in
the ground and he hadn't gone to one
funeral Don long no kidney so you
haven't gone to one funeral no not one
not one these are people he worked with
didn't go to funerals Don long has it
doesn't have kidneys he was working with
Chad Nichols flex wheeler kidney he's
working with Chad Nichols Tom Prince
kidney when I say kidney I'm talking
about transplants Chad Nichols those are
the ones we know about
so what does that say about a guy that
works with all these guys in this camp I
compete against all those guys me and
Kevin live roni and me low Sarge have
refused to have anything to do with Chad
Nichols and that's probably why we're
still health in here but everyone that
he was working with that was in that cam
they're all jacked up Paul delet got
smart and got the hell out but he still
had a couple of hernia surgeries but how
does that happen you have all those
top-notch athletes Ronnie Coleman's in
2001 my last olympia ronnie was getting
ready to go to the emergency room thank
God he was thrown into a bathtub who's
thrown into a bathtub full of ice the
night before you're competing whose guns
only a gallon of water to try to
revitalize yourself because you feel
like you're dying and your coach is
sitting there next to you I mean Michael
Jackson died with his doctor in his room
so I never would give somebody that kind
of control over what I'm doing with my
body especially and they're not
certified doctors I interviewed Tom
Prince recently he's going through
dialysis he looks like he's near death
he can't be 175 pounds and he's defended
he said if he had to do it again he Chad
Nichols is a good friend he would I said
if you didn't have Chad Nichols you
probably would be healthy me and him is
there's no mistake that we're not
friends and he was in the enemy camp in
1998 they were instituting diuretic
testing and Kevin and I were asking for
a blood test because we knew that Chad
was going to show up in 98 this is what
it's open anybody can win we wanted it
to be blood tested instead of piss test
because we need Chad had some plasma
expander including me Oh Sarge
everywhere who wasn't in the Olympia we
were trying to go so far as to keep chat
away from the athletes
meaning to keep him away from the damn
show altogether flex wheeler wanted to
fight me
Kevin loved Roni after the press
conference took his jacket off he was
sweating so much water he wanted to tear
chad nichols a new hole because I didn't
want Chad Nichols anywhere near that
competition and of course Ronnie won the
show flex was second
I think Kevin was third I know I was
fifth place that you just want to try to
come in heavier because I felt it was a
wide-open show I got to put on some so I
came in about five pounds too heavy but
nonetheless I never let that die because
Chad Nichols left a wake of bodies in
his path and he's like a state chairman
and he runs competitions and he's not a
friend of mine and I would have more
respect for him had he gone to some
funerals I mean Don Youngblood was a
good friend of mine he was mutual
friends as my buddy dance Dan English
out of Arkansas so I I don't endorse any
of his practices but you'll find he's
got a very loyal following yeah he was
working with Dallas McCarver when he
started working with Dallas McCarver I
said Dallas has six months to live he
died eight months later so I have a
reason to be pissed
I'm not prophetic I'm not Nostradamus
but I know danger when I see it and I
knew that guy was dangerous back in the
90s so let me ask you this let me ask
you this I got my second video to show
you here and the second video I think
you kind of have an idea what the video
is gonna be this is a second video okay
you know what's about to happen I'm at
my second I'm at the mic okay I was in
seeing this competition this event I
tried to approach Dallas for an
interview prior to him going on stage
what'd he say given he said get the hell
away from him I'm not talking to you
before he walked on this stage ten
minutes before he walked out there get
away from him not talking to you I was
on assignment for muscular development
I said why you're not talking to me says
because you were talking [ __ ] earlier in
the year probably two or three months
move two months before that when he was
working with Chad he went in pose for
Jim Mannion and he wanted to get a look
two weeks out from the Arnold Ohio this
is the Arnold in Australia Dallas went
up to Pittsburgh and posed for Jim
Mannion bent over he was cramping he was
pale white he looked like he was in
distress but the videotape didn't put it
online I looked at it and analyzed it
and I said who does that like who would
ever go in front of I would never go in
front of Joe Weider
totally pale
Dover can't hold my front double bicep
can't hold my stomach in what kind of
analysis was he expecting he didn't like
what I had to say he was working with
Chad Nichols and a couple other people
he took it personal he went in and I
said despite all of that in three weeks
time he's gonna be fighting for first
place against Sedgwick McMillan he got
second place two weeks later the guy
gets carried off the stage and it's
throwing up I was standing on the other
side of the stage when they brought him
back there with the EMTs
I wasn't gloating in his demise but I
knew then he's in distress for one
reason the things that he was doing he's
being fast-tracked taking too much too
soon didn't want to hear the brutal
honest truth I said he should have shut
it down after that contest two months
after that show he went up and guest
posed at the Emerald cup with him about
315 pounds so he didn't shut it down he
actually accelerated he went from dieted
down on stage to putting on another
probably 40 pounds guest posing straight
into the ground prevented so let me ask
you this here's some of the bodybuilders
that have passed away
Dallas McCarver rich Piana under samaan
sir well I have been Muhammad fantasies
in aziza Greg Kovacs Matata so Comerford
Osama the art would Charles door
Hillebrand
men sir both of them brothers rayon my
cross Youngblood you know you know these
active all Matt of all great and there's
many names I don't want to go through
all of them you know that I know all of
them how many of these could have been
prevented I
you can't save someone from themselves
no no no no here's what I mean by let me
and I'm going in a part to help with an
element of bodybuilding that's
uncomfortable to talk about this is what
I mean by I'm not saying you can't
prevent somebody from doing it they're
doing it because they feel the doing
doing part could potentially help them
have an edge over their competitor right
but how much of it has to do with going
and doing too much dosage of the the
steroids that you know that whatever it
is the gh2 pd's how much could that have
been prevented
well we can say the same about wrestling
probably the same thing about football
when you start getting to the brass
tacks
we don't know what any of these guys are
taking I can't I can't paint them with
the same brush you hear the word
steroids you think a needle and a
syringe but there's a lot of different
types of steroids these guys some of
I would attribute probably insulin I'd
probably attribute some of the growth
hormone
there's use and abuse and nobody's
smarter than the next but you know our
sport is made up of a lot of misfits we
come in with a lot of baggage bigger
Axia anorexia some of the guys think of
a little bits good a little bit more is
better
some may have some pre disposed
conditions that exist that might get
exacerbated by growth hormones speed up
the process
we know that mood sir probably diuretics
Vince Comerford is dead but he was over
the age of 50 when he died and he was a
notorious drug user
Paul DeMaio a huge drug user so we don't
know the habits of these body builders
whether they cycled on or cycled off but
I can tell you the ones that are there I
think the one commonality is we would
all agree that they're probably abusers
not users and there's a big difference I
can drink a beer and I'm fine you might
not be able to stop at one you need
three or four and then you're either the
life of the party you're throwing up or
you want to fight everybody in the room
it's the same alcohol just has a
different effect on your height weight
in your shape the bodybuilders when it
comes down to pharmacology are combining
all kinds of stuff a lot of them are
working with trainers that have no idea
getting a blood test isn't the end all
be tall for taking steroids there's you
stand abuse just because you have a
Ferrari doesn't mean you have to drive
200 miles an hour and if you do we could
pretty much bet just about it's a matter
of time so mater there's a lot of these
bodybuilders when you have the means and
the access and you have people pushing
you you don't even know the filter I
remember I saw you interview Ronnie
Coleman I don't think Ronnie Coleman
probably even he was taking stuff he
didn't even know he was taking Chad
Nichols was giving him whatever I give
up whatever it was he didn't know what
it was
so high level athletes with high
intelligence are willing to do whatever
it takes so you're gonna have this list
but this is a very small list by
comparison to the millions of weight
lifters and the thousands of
professionals so there's going to be a
casualty I'm going to complete a front
angle go ahead and what you think I'm
going just the angle I'm taking right
now the angle I'm taking is you said
Sammy urban dude you said in one of the
interviews you said the one guy that I
would be afraid of going on
in 1983 I beat him in an 88 or ATM but
the 83 won right you said you'd be
afraid to go up against that's scary you
look at that guy beautiful God just a
god-like figure Dickerson you know how
to beat Dickerson but he wasn't he was a
mentor oh yeah he had a good physician
yeah I brought uh Kaspari some of these
guys okay good physiques that they have
you good physique but today do you have
any health problems yeah absolutely not
absolutely not that's the point I'm
making so so the point I'm trying to
make you it doesn't even do steroids I
mean obviously are no class in 1991 the
first time two weeks later they took it
away from you and they give 1990 and
they gave it to your the one scene where
he comes up and he says I'm really the
winner yeah but the point is you took
first place right two weeks later they
did that and then it was what it was you
don't hear a lot of times about drug
testing with the guys at the top even
though everybody knows everyone there's
in it this is the point I'm trying to
make on how wide front went from judging
to this okay if the brand is saying like
MBA today saying what Steph Curry
two-time MVP okay mm-hmm Steve Nash
two-time MVP go back Shaq wilt Russell
Giants everybody wants to be sent or you
know you want to be this guy David
Robinson you know Hakeem you know you
Inc all these guys no one cares about
these centers right okay so two
different games that it's Anthony Davis
Gianna's yeah it's completely different
kind of gayness but but a part of it is
on the player and a part of it is on
what the brand is also building up right
so in the judges part why why don't they
sit there and say look if there's
anything with any gut we see like its
massive point reduction they did they
did it with phil heat that's why he lost
some mr. Olympia
but I'm not but I'm going back with it
right now to move for 90 s yeah I'm
going back and then I'm going forward
right because a lot of these guys passed
we they're not today these guys are
byproduct of what happened to 90s what
most of these names are not today's
names a lot of these names except for a
couple of them are recent but you know
pianos a couple years ago most of them
are the 90s guys right what if the
judging comes back and says here's what
we're gonna be doing you know Calvin
Klein models for a decade you thought
you had to be nice
pounds and you know you're looking like
you know what I'm talking about it was
nothing attractive about it right what
Kevin Kline made everybody think that's
sexy right and 60 years ago sexy was
Marilyn Monroe voluptuous you know nice
with eyes and butt and a fake and
hundred forty five pounds maybe not the
wellness division coming and now we have
now we have concur dashing right what
I'm saying is to not get the black eye
do you think the mr. Olympia brand needs
to go and kind of start recognizing
certain other behaviors well there
aren't they with classic physique
I mean Briana Ansley and Chris bum said
that was highly contested Brandon Currie
is not a 250-pound what I'm saying
actually no no I'm with you there
so I'm going to the part of saying with
the judging side that if mr. Olympia
goes to kind of a build up some guys
that have your kind of a physique and
not pressure and go fill to want to go
to the next size and want to bulk up a
little bit more and it kind of brings up
that phase well I think we've got to be
mindful there are no genres there are no
lip rodda's I mean Brandon curry doesn't
fit into that category
well you bone it doesn't hottie to open
doesn't I mean the gene pool is just not
there I mean I'm a teenage national
champion Lee Haney was a teen national
champion Jay Cutler was a teen national
champion
Dennis Newman I mean the guys that had
that pedigree are just not there I mean
you got Johnny Jackson coming out at 49
years old dextrous 50 years old these
guys are again guarantee if you take the
average age of these guys in the Olympia
they're 35 years plus when I was coming
up I mean Lee Haney retired at 31 years
old with eight Olympia's I got out of 35
years old so the gene pool is it's a
different it's a different era man and
right now in 2020 and it's barely
starting we don't see that next Phil
Heath coming up but there's always one
right Brandon Currie is not new he's
been here for a minute he just he's
arrived and it's a matter of attrition
because again if you throw in Phil you
throw in big romney you throw in Phil
Heath
I'm sorry I Chi grain maybe Brandon's
not mr. Olympia but he is because he
showed up this year there's no guarantee
that it doesn't get injured on the way
and we could wind up with somebody I
just couldn't
imagine William Bonin being mr. Olympia
in terms of all of the guys that are mr.
Olympia and then you would have a
William boning it just didn't sound
right it didn't seem right it didn't
look right
although Brandon Currie fit in there
based on what he was sized up against I
think we got to get to a point where you
know I don't think mr. Olympia will ever
be not be the main attraction of the
Olympia weekend but we got to accept
that that title could change hands every
single year moving forward that reign of
seven and eight
there's nobody with number one the youth
or the look that's coming up to do that
kind of dominance that Phil Heath had
Ronnie Coleman and J color if you're 22
today would you go to the same rod would
mister miss Rowley because it's a
numbers game listen I loved body blowing
I wouldn't do it for free I mean Ronnie
comes from a different ELQ if that prize
money is what it is I'm in it because I
would have the potential and I would
think I could beat what's there I think
what's there now is more beatable then
when I started when I started I mean
what was what was there I was like it
Greek gods I mean and you had it ran the
gamut mind you Lila Branagh was getting
second and rich Gaspard was getting
second so on one hand it was
unfathomable that I could be there and
on the other hand it was realistic that
if I keep doing what I'm doing I could
be there and I woke up one day and I was
there when I heard Lila Branagh
announced in third place in Sean ray and
second in 94 I mean I arrived actually
beat him in 93 for me that was my small
Olympia victory because I held the brada
in such high esteem the way I held Bob
Paris now if we saw somebody come out
looking like Bob Paris
today I plug him right in there I mean
that would be somebody you can get
behind and change the entire look of the
mr. Olympia weekend if you had a Bob
Paris like physique six-foot tall
230 pounds not overtly muscular not
really grainy and hard we just got
caught up in an era where the bar was
just being raised so high and even even
during my time the Lee Haney was the
only one to finish his career I think
better than when he started
his last Olympian 91 he could sail off
into the sunset Dorian Yates you needed
a wheelchair for him Ronnie Coleman he's
kind of sloppy at the end Phil Heath was
not what he was when he started his
reign so these bodybuilders they don't
get better then typically get worse
Dexter's found a way to kind of be
consistently consistent but he's nowhere
near the 200 2008 he's found a way that
yeah to maximize what he has without
trying to blow it all out as hell that's
the question for Dexter cuz I wouldn't
know I just I imagine mean by that is
that a Chad get a hold of him or no he's
always work with like Charles class okay
he's had various George Farah he's
worked with people that I think are
respected books Charles wasn't a guru
room he's a coach he's a legend chad is
a guru that doesn't have the medical
background and I don't have the respect
for him his wife was a four-time is
Olympian that he dried out nicely
she was the game changer and the female
side of things cuz he dried her out
Ronnie Coleman didn't win the Olympic
because he got big Ronnie Coleman dried
out through whatever protocols Chad put
him on you saw him in 98 he was never
that dry in his whole career that's why
he fogged over everyone and then
everyone wanted to jump onto that
bandwagon and he got some people but me
and Kevin Love Rowan he stayed true to
our own independence and we did our own
thing
yeah I'm cured I'm cured in a what
direction because the judging dictates
what they get points for that's all it I
think the judging dictates what
direction the talents going to do when
you say we don't have a pool of genetics
like we did obviously the genetics are
there the level of inspiration to want
to get a guy like that to want to come
out and compete may not be there because
they may take a different route so I
don't know I don't know what's going to
happen I don't know what they do with
the judging side the only thing I'm
thinking when I'm looking at these names
here is there a way to prevent more of
these things happening because this has
a black eye for the Brian that's not
something that you can prevent because
no one is in there with these guys
except themselves and they're only they
know their limitations maybe they don't
know their limitations but these guys
are dying of diuretics the Dyer dying of
overuse of growth hormone insulin
combined and also doing recreational
drugs yeah we're gonna have that just
like rock and roll you have people doing
Prince die whoever saw that coming what
are some of the comment you know to come
in for the person that doesn't follow
this stuff that hasn't read the
asteroid's Bible version 1 2 3 4 or
ageless man or any of this stuff right
never read one of them you've never read
one of them no so you so you're not the
guy that studies I don't think I really
can tell you what a diet
Annabelle will do versus anavar so you
never see the research before you
started Titan I I pretty much through
trial and error learned what was good
for genre and your health yes I didn't
tell you how many calories are on a
potato I couldn't tell you how many
grams of food I eat I never measured I
don't know how big my arms are I
couldn't care less how big my waist is
the only reason I knew my weight was
because typically there's a scale on the
day of the show but I didn't monitor my
progress on the scale like Ronnie said
he said something like he didn't have
mirrors the mirror was my best friend I
consider myself an artist I needed that
mirror I wasn't gonna go in there in
outmuscle Dorian Yates I needed to make
sure that I was hitting my poses right
yeah I took a page out of LeBron ah to
the page out of Muhammad Mak away I took
a page out of Chris Dickerson and Bob
Paris I was a physique artist I've never
considered myself to be a bodybuilder
because I wasn't building to get big and
nor was I using nor were they using
anabolics to get big I mean I was
training twice a day two and three hours
at a time
eat sleeping and training I knew exactly
what they did and I studied up on him
but I couldn't give you my protocol and
say here try this I would never give
advice to someone to take something
you're not gonna find me talking about
direction on how to use anabolics with
anybody because I just don't have the
the wealth of knowledge let alone on the
nutrition side I was not a guy that was
scientific like Dorian said he wrote all
the stuff down and honey this is
genetics on yeah I can't explain it it's
like I know for a fact Shaquille O'Neal
is probably the crappiest free-throw
shooter in the history of the game but
you know he probably shot a million
free-throws in practice he just couldn't
get it down right whereas we could see
you could always Bank on somebody like
Steph Curry hit that free throw to win
the game he'd do his eyes closed Kobe to
for me I just go into the gym I lift
weights and stuff happens let me ask you
how close were you to correct Titus I
was always curious and how he was as an
Indonesia I think I showed him where to
buy his house I was there with him when
he met his wife Kelly and in Michigan
and he had good intentions at times but
you can't get out of your own way when
you have an ego that big
I mean we became we butted heads because
just with the athletes rep thing I was
trying to get some changes he wanted to
do he always had the brighter bigger
idea so he had an alpha male personality
he was a hothead I never saw him getting
a fight course he won't he called me out
a couple times one to fight me but if
anybody was gonna say who's gonna do
something this crazy to this degree that
Craig Titus did I think all the body
builders probably would have said
Craig's cake oh so you oh so you scream
he was capable of doing song yeah you
know at the end of his career he wasn't
hyped up on steroids he was using drugs
man I mean I think most people would say
he was probably a drug addict at the
time I mean I went to the USA that year
that that happened he's standing outside
the USA smoking a cigarette it didn't
give a crap ghostly white pale I mean he
was he was fully into his recreational
drugs and I think that whole murder
thing thing happened under the veil of a
drug-induced stupor that he probably
still can't even believe it actually
happened because he was way out of it
that can happen to any sport I'm just
I'm just trying to see you know okay got
it
behind backstage stories so you know
Kevin says a story about you Kevin says
with him last night
yeah a dinner with him last night but
you by the way I'm all I always like
this physique in the army had pictures
on the wall
I always liked Kevin had a very
different kind of a physique I mean I
don't know you know I actually can't say
another physique that matches Kevin's
physique it was very different
yeah of a physique yet but he told a
story one time he says backstage he's
dehydrated and he's talking to you and
he says hey yeah Shawn listen man I need
some can you give me some of those
orange slice yeah you know like no I'm
not giving you orange slice you go get
your own right so he said there's a
different madness with Shawn behind
closed doors but it's competition when
you when you compete against each other
do you have any crazy stories against
other guys like a Yates or Ronnie or a
Haney or any of those stories that you
have yeah no there was nothing crazy
about showing up backstage at the
Olympia listen I mean I walk in there
and it's like this this is what I'm
looking at I'm five seven 210 pounds but
I got to stand next to what that's what
they look like it was very intimidating
to think that I've got ignore them on
stage I didn't you're not
I tried to squeeze in a couple of pose
downs and got muscled out I mean elbows
flying I almost knocked me off the stage
because I try to duck underneath it yeah
so I felt like I was in a washing
machine in Ronnie Coleman and Kevin
these guys are like you know in my mind
they're like raging fighting for the
real estate but there was this wasn't
this was big business man I mean we
weren't we were more sociable off stage
backstage it was more like a church you
know you just do your meditation and you
do your thing
I didn't have to meditate I got there I
was full of energy I was this is what I
trained for it's what I live for it's
like game day for me I never felt in
their death I didn't cramp up I only got
one cramp in my life and a bodybuilding
show in 92 in Helsinki Finland I tried
to dry out because it's a transatlantic
flight and I try to dry and I just dried
out a little bit too much I cramped up
in my hamstring very briefly but I never
felt one that I didn't have a shot at
winning and two that this is a miserable
experiment I always thought that on any
given day I could be mr. lumpy which is
what got me out of bed I never showed up
at the Olympia except for that the one
time when I came in heavy in 98 I
thought I spilled over a little bit like
[ __ ] you know five pounds yeah but I
felt that like the day before the
Olympia every Olympia I went in I felt
like I was a competitor except like 1988
my first one my rookie year that was
just way too busy to even be a
competitor but I was the biggest fan of
bodybuilding in my first Olympia that I
didn't matter that I wasn't in the hunt
but every year after that from 92 2001
you can believe I went in there thinking
I was gonna win yeah we got into a fight
with any of these guys or no was no body
builders are like cats they make a lot
of noise but they don't necessarily I
pushed a lot of buttons trust me Lee
Haney's one guy whose buttons you
couldn't push I mean he was like the old
man of the bunch even though he's not
that old he's but Dorian wasn't someone
you wanted to stare down you know Dorian
was until you saw him walk by you you
knew he was coming through I I almost
got in the beef with one of his trainers
at the time backstage in 96 with
Weinberger but it's because Weinberger
was in a room helping mr. Olympia warm
up and we were all out to fend for
ourselves but I never had any issues on
game day
interesting yeah Dorian seems like the
stoic guy that doesn't
say a lot and his look is just gonna
make you think yeah you know as much as
people want to pit us against each other
I never knew Dorian until we were done
and when we were done like he thought he
retired in 97
my last Olympia guest post for him in
2001 but we actually guest post together
in 1988 so I saw him coming he arrived
three years later but I saw him coming
up and he was a beast but I didn't like
I didn't want to know Dorian because he
was the enemy like you don't want to be
friends with these guys so by time it
was all said and done I really he's
pretty cerebral he's mellowed out he
turned the corner from partying and you
know he's the guy that I would look
forward to having dinner with when going
over to England I would seek him out but
as a bodybuilder during my bodybuilding
years we couldn't have been more
different yeah I I enjoyed the
conversations with him he he thinks very
different couple pictures you've shot so
this is you which by the way this is a
sick picture you got here this is
another one of those pictures that just
doesn't make sense when you see this
today what do you think about well that
was my last year of competition I mean I
I went out kind of the way I came in a
lot of people in 87 thought I was the
heir apparent that I would win the mr.
Olympia and I actually believed that
would too
I didn't know I would spend the rest of
my life trying to pursue that and going
out of the game leaving them wanting
more
was probably the best move for me rather
than try to come back like Kevin and
flex so that's an that's a nice full
look it's probably ten days out from the
mr. Olympia and I'm satisfied with that
that's a pretty sick picture this one
here this is another one of those where
you end flex have one similar like this
you know which one I'm talking about
would flex yeah no no Gary Phillips this
is paraben all this is actually
backstage walking off the Olympia stage
to stand in front of his white dropcloth
backstage this competitions I got fourth
this is my last mr. Olympia parents and
I couldn't be more proud of the
photography that / bernal did because it
brought out everything as a fan that I
would want to see on my physical this is
last year in your place flow 2001
interesting do you see all your flaws or
no like I do I see I see my flaws from
the standpoint that look I only have so
much to work with I'm five seven if I
was five seven 230 pounds you wouldn't
see the detail I was an artist so this
is it right there this one my facial
expression reminds me of your young you
printer and I always like you'll burn as
an actor but the face is just as much as
important as the body not to mention I
knew that the midsection is the focal
point of everything just as important
absolutely usual jaws and all that the
look period the presence depending on
what pose you're hitting whether you're
smiling or you're not
this style of pose wouldn't look right
if I was smiling and Bob Paris perfected
this pose I stole it from him way back
when I got my little thing to John Brown
has one similar but hitting this pose
there's more that's going on than me
just trying to show my small midsection
I'm showing the serratus on the side I'm
trying to flex my tricep a little bit
I'm pushing my hand up against my
hamstring it's very uncomfortable I'm on
dirt right it's what is this thing
that's behind my house in chino hills'
but when I hit a pose it had purpose and
it started with the facial expression
what's your waist here what's your
waistline I have no idea I okay this was
again about 10 days out what do you
think well when you see this this was
the shot that I had I think this is the
93 Olympia if I'm not mistaken
for flex wheeler got second place and I
was third place the first time I beat
lebra de my frontal bicep at that time
was probably my worst pose so I'm proud
of word by front double bicep evolved
into I didn't like looking at that front
double bicep in 93 I wasn't hitting it
right but putting the Prada in my
rearview I was done I mean I knew how
good Flex was I was upset that flex was
smoother from the back and the
hamstrings
but that's flexes pose that's the pose
you want to make a trophy out of when I
see the front double bicep trophy I
think a flex wheeler but taking LeBron
out was the crowning moment for me
that's pretty sick because it's the one
guy that's I cannot yeah he was one of
my idols man I lovely what do you think
about here this is pretty sick this is
the 91 and I'm like holy crap
so this 91 yes that's the 91 let the
events Taylor beat me for the first time
and I predicted that he wouldn't be
because he's like 10 years old I mean
and they said if Vince Taylor ever beats
me I'm retiring so that gave him that
fire did that's up right but I got fifth
place there in in Orlando Florida but to
to be on there with Lee Haney and Albert
Beckles forget everybody else
Albert Beckles was second place in 1985
when I won the Junior World
Championships over in Australia and he
the guest poseur he got second place to
Lee Haney in 1985 so that those two guys
standing there and I'm on that stage and
then I got Robby Robinson that's a
historic lineup for me I wasn't ready in
91 I won the Arnold Classic went on tour
kind of missed my peak Ohio right on a
classic Ohio
yeah but this was Orlando when Dorian
Yates did his first Olympia got it got
it signed out memories there so this
right here the big guys went one the
game changed a little bit I never
thought a Marcus rule I thought it was
an ugly slabs of muscle that just didn't
flow properly and look very drug-induced
Paulding Paul delet I never really
considered a threat of mine he was big
and freaky like the Incredible Hulk
his back was incredibly weak his skin
was incredibly thick but the silhouette
and the the size and the girth you could
not take that away I was there when he
won the North America to turn pro but I
thought this is a physique that's so
incomplete that if it ever beats me I
got work to do and he actually did in
1996 he got third place at the Ironman
Championships second in Ironman I got
third then we went to the Arnold Classic
and he beat me there he was fourth and I
was fifth that was the year I said never
again and I wanted a placing second in
the mr. Olympia that year and beat Paul
and beat Vince Taylor again Jay Cutler
that's probably one of his most iconic I
was actually a cover shot for Jay and
Jay got all the props for me what a lot
of people know about Jay is he's a
six-time six-time first runner-up at the
Olympia to go with the four Olympia
titles and the three Arnold Classic
titles he no one ever mentions that he
was second place six times and there's
no one ever there's no one ever that's
been sixth place second place six times
yeah six time runner-up destroy Olympia
sage you know that and you follow this
Wow
I don't know that it's a record what do
you think about here well there's a lot
of thoughts there man because forget the
fact that I thought I should have beat
during aids this was 94 yeah I forget
the fact that I thought I should've beat
during AIDS I think that Dorian in 94
was just a little too sloppy listen he
was big there's no question you can't
take that away the color was running all
off of his body the bicep terror was
very noticeable but when he put his
hands down the obliques were hanging
over the shorts so for that matter you
got to go with the one with the fewest
flaws forget it that I'm not trying to
perfect but I had fewer flaws on the day
and this is where the sport of body
Willie could have turned at the corner
and gone a totally different rec
direction which would have favored me
but I pretty much knew by the time I got
the finals that the people that were
judging that show we're not gonna change
their opinion but they could have done
the right thing and I thought they
didn't that year I didn't hold the
personal against story and I held it
against the system I'd be curious judges
are still around okay so let's talk
about some of the stuff today
let's not like some of the stuff today
okay our buddy here from here on yeah
what do you think about this chain it's
not a favorite physique of mine he
doesn't have the Liberata esque type
shape the calves are kind of light the
waist is not very tapered he's got some
good muscularity the quads don't have
the type of sweet sweeps I like but he's
competing in a lineup where he he can do
very well mmm
this is not one it's gonna do very well
in my year my era absolutely not hop 10
not in the top 10 I can name 10
physiques that in my era that could beat
hottie but he's right where he needs to
be in this era how about obviously we
know we'll feel but I'm more asking
about our buddy here yeah big Rami is
just a promise that hasn't been kept he
reminds me a lot of cederick mcmillian
on the day of the Olympia Romney has
some properties that are really good he
just hasn't tried to sculpt it those
quadriceps you should never ever press
he's gotta bring those quads down if his
quads were down down it would look more
palatable because the arms are so big he
has potential right now to come into
this year's Olympia and do some things
do some things means first or something
he could do some things because of the
people he's up against including Brandon
Currie by the way do you think you can
win it by the way Brandon Currie beat
him in in the his last Olympia Brandon
was fifth and he was six place he wasn't
in shape but him in shape Brandon Currie
hadn't beaten him so I'd like to see
that rubber match to see which direction
they go what are your thoughts on those
somebody I was always a fan about
somebody as a physique I didn't know him
obviously personally but as a physique I
thought it was interesting yeah I I
wasn't a big fan of Nasser's physique
here he beat Dorian this is 97 I'm
assuming he beat Dorian not only from
the front but the back
and that's where Dorian's strength was
and he beat it he just could just beat
him I was I was third in this
competition but Nasir was full of stuff
man I mean he put oil in his arms he put
oil in his shoulders he put him in his
calves so when you know these things
that some of the body goes yeah surgery
for shoulders or absolutely so me being
an artist knowing the things that NASA
was doing I'm not gonna say it's an
unfair playing field but to the expert I
you can see the things he was doing and
he should have been marked down for it
and later in his career he couldn't make
the top ten of a regular open show let
alone a Olympia so let's do the one that
all your peers have been doing you know
whether it's Ronnie whether it's Dorian
whether it's flex flex was the nicest
out of all of them Ronnie's reaction was
very different and then Dorian was just
the first one that went through it
current era against your era no none of
these guys in the top ten none of them I
said the top ten so the one that could
be the top ten would probably be Dexter
Johnson but the other guy's not I think
tenth would be Brandon and it's not a
slap in Brandon's face but those other
guys no no I mean roelly winklaar for as
good as he is he couldn't beat me Losar
czev in me Lesar Jeff I think got one
10th place in the Olympia definitely
couldn't beat a Chris Cormier the these
guys are right where they need to be for
their timing and they're lucky that
Dexter is not 10 years younger couldn't
be the extra fee was 10 years younger
Dexter Dexter and his prime couldn't
make the top six of the Olympia and I
was there say that one more time
Dexter eNOS prime couldn't make the top
six during your era here in my hair yeah
I think he actually fighting with Chris
Cormier for sixth place there's no
question Dexter it was he was in the 99
2000 and 2001 Olympia with me he doesn't
like me to remind him that he didn't
beat me he's beating everyone else he
beat Kevin and he beat flags
he didn't beat me and he hates it when I
remind him of that but I'm a little bit
older I think of four years older than
Dexter but at the time if we're talking
about than 99 Olympia competition Dexter
we would be fighting Chris come here to
get into the top six Chris Chris Chris
was another guy that I like to follow
just something about Chris
that I like we him and I were going back
and forth the other day he follows the
content that we were having a
conversation about it so speed round
I'll give you names tell me the first
thing that comes to your mind okay we're
coming down to the wire here a a name
first thought that comes to mind Kevin
loved Rome that's my boy man I mean we
he's probably the closest one I'm too
and bodybuilding we have a love-hate
brother relationship he didn't like what
I had to say about his comeback for the
Olympia but he sometimes the truth hurts
and when you hear from your friend you
know even warping it's even more painful
but he's come full circle and
acknowledge that you know some of the
things I was saying we're coming from a
good place
Ronnie Coleman he's one of those good ol
boys man we're in Texas Ronnie's a good
ol boy there's nothing bad you can say
about Ronnie and he should have took his
foot off the gas a long time ago
he doesn't blame bodybuilding for his
injuries or lame surgeons but I believe
it's the bodybuilding if you have taken
his foot off the gas when he retired
that I think we'd be talking to a
different Ronnie Dorniers
Dorian as if he was a game changer
because that's when it changed when he
arrived he if there's no Dorian Yates
you probably have Sean Ray as a mr.
Olympia you probably have a flex wheeler
Dorian changed the game he ushered in
the masked monsters because I no one
ever thought Lee Haney was a masked
monster because he had 25 yeah he had
the nice shape but Dorian assured in
something that brought out the bigness
and the size and it was a game changer
for sure flex wheeler the enigma I mean
flex you don't know if you're dealing
with flex or Kenny from one moment to
the next and mind you I've met Ken
wheeler
back in 1988 helped me move into my
apartment kind of mentored him a little
bit in the beginning with any he took on
the flex wheeler persona and that's a
whole nother gangster thug style but I
got to tell you he comes from a good
place I think he's come full circle I
mean when you get humbled you start to
realize the things that really matter
I'm glad that he is starting to
recognize that you know people are more
important than things our after Kobe
died he called me and I had a very
emotional conversation together with
what happened with Kobe Jay Cutler Jays
a businessman IJ hasn't changed from
when I met him coming into the game my
news first Olympia wasn't a one this
2000 and
like twelfth or something or 14th and
all that all that success and he's still
the same J that I met back then I just
did a seminar with him over the weekend
but I like the idea that he realizes his
his seniority in the sport and he is
genuinely trying to pay it forward and
give it back you can't take it with you
six times runner up and that's nuts too
yeah
Bill Phillips he was also a game changer
if you want to use the game changer my
training partner married one of the his
girls that did the body for life
transformation the very first one so I
was there I was part of the whole
metrics thing in the beginning of 93
with dr. Conley and Jeff Everson in
those guys bill was ahead of his time it
seems like he kind of cashed his chips
in and went away but you know he's done
a lot of things along the way that
continue to stay relevant today he came
along at the right time without Ville
Phillips I think we're missing a lot of
components that are relevant to today's
bodybuilding how about your best friend
Lee Priest
I think Leah he's a loss he's lost bro I
mean Lee's animosity towards me goes
back to me taking one of his girlfriends
actually didn't take his girlfriend it
was the next girlfriend that I wind up
being with and he never got over it and
I think that if there's no Sean ray then
leap rhesus talked about with even more
esteem he never beat me I was never in
competition with him but every time I
turned around he was dropping my name
and a negative sense and sometimes you
know you get attention drawn to you when
you call out the guy that's got the
biggest mouth I had the mouth I had the
accolades and he's a guy that's still
trying to find himself you can tell with
all the paint all over his face he's
easy he's running from something
Lee liberado Lee Lee brought up he got
them masked with class everything I did
I was copying him so when you saw me
show up not in sweats wearing a suit and
a tie in my posing routines Lee set the
standard for that raised the bar
professionalism I wanted to be using I
wanted to be looked at and kind of
regarded this that way and and he didn't
teach me that I he has a letter that I
wrote him when my career was over my
career was over or his career was over
one of the two but I made sure that he
knew that I appreciated what's
impressive for you to be able to say
something like that yeah Gaspari blue
collar I mean
I get rich and ice he sponsors my show
every year in Hawaii I've never seen
somebody do so much with so little rich
was a big block of wicked butter when he
first came on the scene I remember
witnessing come up through the national
championships and I was very envious
that he was training with Lee Haney as a
training partner I thought what an
advantage he had over everyone when I
won the Junior World Championships my
training partner 20 years old said that
I could beat rich Gaspari
and rich Gaspari I think got third in
the mr. Olympia Championships that year
and I said no way I mean he came into
our gym he was doing a video his very
first training video I never mind rich
all the time that my training partner
said I would beat you one day and I did
not that's the one thing I didn't
believe and then in 1990 he did not
believe it should I didn't believe I
could beat because I mean he was barely
22 years old getting third in the
Olympia and I thought it was just so
far-fetched and he was training with Lee
Haney and he he went on to get you know
three first runner ups and in 1990 I
surpassed him and just another one of
those milestones in my career that
validated that I chose the right sport
David Becker
I don't really know Dave I haven't had
we had dinner twice I don't know him I
do know that he reminds me of Joe Weider
he resembles Joe Weider
I don't know if he has the same passion
as Joe Weider in terms of what to do
with this sport of bodybuilding but he's
hiring the right people at the right
time to do the right things so a lot of
things you pointed on that haven't been
happening hearing them being verbalized
could potentially turn into things that
might materialize because we're at a
point where he's at least willing to
listen to the people he brings it to his
office and if he's willing to listen and
let people do what needs to be done I
think some of the things you were
discussing earlier could potentially the
next three to five years get done and we
could be in a totally different space
it's good to hear
Robin Cheng oh man I remember Robin when
he was carrying flex wheelers gym bag he
was working for ESPN on American Muscle
would lose a week that's how far back we
go walking we're going back to the early
90s when Robin came on the scene and I
got to tell you it's very cerebral
caring and he's thoughtful to the
athletes I
think that Robin is a very diplomatic
player in this sport and he grew up in
this sport so if you want to know how
things should be done how people should
be treated I think Robin has a firm
grasp on how those things run cool silly
and I I would have to say because I was
closer to Phil when he first turned pro
then after cuz I work for a different
magazine and I work from muscular
development he worked for muscle fitness
so we've had this big chasm come between
us so he's somebody different now but I
gotta say he's his self-made I don't
think anybody can take credit for what
Phil's done the word gift is appropriate
because when we saw him we said holy
crap this is not something that you can
just develop he's born with it he's got
a gift I think he could do a little bit
more with it than what he's done but
maybe he's doing with it what he wants I
mean to whom much is given much is
expected
I come from the bodybuilding elk like
that Olympia is the Holy Grail he's got
seven of them he's got different ideas
what each one of those mean to him but I
gotta tell you I think he's done the
best with what he could with it
I'd like to see him do more in the
landscape of bodybuilding as a
figurehead if the powers that be are not
allowing him that's a different story
but I'd love to have him be more
relevant because I think for the past
year he's been a little bit too
invisible and the best thing for
bodybuilding right now is it Phil came
back takes his title because I believe
that that has his name on it and if
you're asking me to give him advice Phil
go back to your first love
get that title tie that record and then
go for number nine he's got he has a
very small window at his age that he
could actually wind up with nine all he
has to do is what he's always done fix
the problem that's the easy part he
doesn't have to go build up bigger arms
or a bigger back but when you sit on the
sidelines for a year and you become
civilized like coming home from war and
they call you back up to go back it's
it's not as easy as said than done
because getting under that weight doing
the things that you have to do it takes
a very disciplined mind and I'm not sure
he's not too civilized right now he may
be a little too civilized for that he
can't come back to fail like he would
have to no he's going to war and going
to war with these
guys Phil Heath is a shoo-in for me I
mean I there's nothing he needs to do
other than just come in a little bit
lighter Ronnie Coleman did it in 2001
when he won the Arnold Classic
championship before he almost died in
2001 Phil doesn't need to die to win
number 8 Phil comes back he would send
shockwaves through all of these guys
because he has the he has the tools
he doesn't have to rebuild anything he
got penalized for what they were gonna
be penalizing him he knew what he was
gonna get penalized for now just fix it
and come back and get your title was the
last time you guys spoke I talked to
Phil over the new year and I basically
told him he needed to call Jim Mannion
he needed a culture man yes okay last
one
Arnold Schwarzenegger without Arnold how
to think there's a lot of us
I mean Arnold made this what it is he
put the lipstick on the sport man if you
don't have those pictures of Arnold
training at Gold's with Franco and and
you know marrying a kid nnedi and doing
the movies and I mean creating the
Arnold Classic we what do you have
without him we don't have it I mean I
certainly wouldn't be promoting the Sean
Ray classic when there are no class that
came out of that one day I want the Sean
Ray classic interesting right I mean he
he's affected people in the domino
effect that I don't even think he knows
and and for me to be working with Arnold
every year and for me to be able to be
in that universe how it's very vast and
I'm actually going to his Museum in
Austria in March I get to go to grad
school he's the closest thing to a Joe
Weider that we have in terms of being
revealed you know I mean he we God
forbid we lose Arlen and we're all gonna
go but when that day comes it's gonna be
a very sad day for my oh I bet yeah I
bet it is top five greatest bodybuilders
of all time in your opinion all time
well Arnold's in there because without
Arnold you don't even have the blueprint
so we start with our own work our way
back
Lee hey knees in there of course we
evolved and we got bigger legs we got
bigger calves we got the bigger back I I
really love surgery surgery oliva
surgery leave is the game changer
because I think he showed that you can
put mass where mass isn't supposed to be
I mean he did it in Cuba like you mean
in the 60s and he did it at a time where
it's not fashionable but more
importantly for Serge
as the joints right I mean did you know
buddy's been born with that type of
configuration I gotta put Ronnie Coleman
in there because Ronnie did what no
other human can do in terms of the girth
I never thought of Ronnie as a beautiful
bodybuilder and I've always thought a
body body has to have some beauty to it
nothing pretty about Ronnie's physique
but there's nobody else that can
duplicate that because of the amount of
weights that he lifted we're never gonna
see anybody lift that kind of weight he
was a power lifter didn't look like
Ronnie you got to do what Ronnie's doing
and there's no one gonna do what Ronnie
did so I found a little satisfaction and
beating him in the early years because I
can always brag about it I beat him but
of course once he wanted he it was a
stranglehold and even though he ended
kind of poorly yeah it was kind of it
was gonna change because of the things
he was doing and I think we're missing
one more which I would say Samira knows
Samira knew from me you put some stuff
for me and you got to remember when I
started when I started I didn't have a
Phil Keith I didn't have a Dorian I
didn't have a Jay Cutler but what's very
impressionable we all remember our first
I remember the first time I lifted
weights right I remember the first time
I open the magazine and I saw Bob Harris
before I saw any of these guys but when
I saw Samir Bannu in 1983 as mr. Olympia
the split in the bicep with the Lions
with Betty wieder with the Sandow trophy
and Mohammed Mack away there in the
shadows I thought there's I thought it
was six feet tall and maybe 400 pounds
you couldn't put him in a box so free if
not for Sameer I probably wouldn't have
gone to this business the way that I did
as an artist I never lost the artistry
of bodybuilding which is why you never
saw me with the bloated gut and all that
other stuff I posed out of shape once
once and there's like a couple of
pictures floating around the internet
that remind me that I made that mistake
but Sameer to me was what mr. Olympia
was supposed to be all those other guys
that are worthy of that title they're
great champions but like I never aspired
to be a Phil Heath and maybe it's cuz
he's younger than me but with Sameer
being older and laying the footprints
that's what I kind of always kept in
mind while I was training in the gym
it's very tough to have prior
generations but somebody that's younger
than them yeah in the list I don't you
know even in basketball and baseball
it's just a different kind of
it's almost like you have to go to
another sport I gotta go to another see
a younger player doing something that
I've always wished that I could be right
like I always I always wanted to be like
Mike Tyson right but you can
bodybuilding you can't be that way but
Mike was just the beast and an animal
that's how I approach the weights and I
took my my battles out on my training
partner it's the way that Mike did on is
so I Paul is the first to say this the
longest bodybuilding interview we've
ever done I don't know what I've never
done it this long I want to see this
Kizer so long as we've ever done we've
touched a lot of topics
I certainly hope the IFB B's watch and I
certainly hope the Olympia folks are
watching obviously the bodybuilding
folks are watching because it come visit
us here all the time but there was a and
I also appreciate you being a class act
for allowing me to push you and you
pushing back and giving your points
because I think that's how I get
educated sure for me you've been in this
thing for you pretty much your entire
life it's not my part I just appreciate
the sport and I admire what many of you
did with your physique and I'm gonna
give the exposure to the business
because I like this business so
appreciate you for coming I appreciate
your answers and hopefully I will see
you in September at the mr. Olympia so I
can kind of see from the business
standpoint yeah well someone leave you
this parting thing is that a lot of the
bodybuilders think that the industry
owes them something I mean everything
I've gotten was from bodybuilding and I
think a lot of the guys before me can
say the same thing but you reap what you
sow like I'm not mr. Olympia but I'm
still able to go out and get sponsors
for the things that I'm involved in that
happened to do with bodybuilding we're
the next generation of bodybuilders are
gonna come from so which enables me to
do the Sean Ray Classic which enables me
to send people to the mr. Olympia to
watch it to send people out to my show
in Hawaii to watch it so representing
companies like the watch company like
the clothing company like the tanning
company it enables me to be able to give
back and also feed my kids so it becomes
a business you can't just rely on the
prize money right you have to find what
find your niche and it's not through
social media it's through relationships
I told greed with that and obviously you
know where I stand with some of the
stuff on what Olympia could do to give
them a like really reach out a little
bit more but I fully agree with you
and although if you want to follow and
send them a message we'll put
you [ __ ] so we'll put the Instagram
account and any websites you got for
following what with Shana Zune we're
gonna put all the links below
having said that brothers after limit
I'm and really I enjoyed it thanks for
hanging up this is great thank you so if
the topic of mist or Olympian what we
talked about today bodybuilding
intrigues you there's two other videos I
want you to watch another interview I
did with Ronnie Coleman if you want to
watch I click over here or a sit that I
did with during the eights when there's
a six time with Stroh Olympia the other
ones an eight-time both of them
priceless if you like bodybuilding and
mr. Olympia and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please
subscribe thanks for watching everybody
buh-bye
[Music]